bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille mehdi el mhamdi qui est
doctorant à l'école polytechnique
fédérale de lausanne en informatique et
en particulier qui travaillent sur des
problématiques d'intelligence
artificielle et de sécurité en option
serti ciel et de biologie théorique
également aujourd'hui dit comment ça va
très bien je sens que tu as beaucoup de
choses à nous dire qui a préféré toni
qui démontre que tu penses être vrai
cette interview est très intéressante
ah ça c'est un truc que tu penses être
vrai oui mais lausanne et dans le canton
de vaud suisse
elle est en train de naître ambiance et
on en fait je pense que beaucoup de gens
en fait des fois débattre comme ça genre
personne n'a dit un truc plutôt vrai la
personne paie lui dit non mais lausanne
est ensuite essayé de vraies réponses
souvent à côté puis je pense que ce qu'a
réussi parce qu'en fait on a souvent
tendance à vouloir dire un truc est en
fait on n'écoute pas du coup ajustons
pas un truc bras et puis il y aussi un
côté on essaie de gagner en
respectabilité où on autorise t bonds
avant de parler de tout ça est ce qu'on
peut faire un petit peu peux te
connaître un petit peu plus parce que
vont aujourd'hui en informatique mais
c'était toujours voulu faire de
l'informatique a jamais jamais j'aurais
rigolé à l'idée d'être en informatique
d'ailleurs je ne sais toujours pas
programmée une fois j'ai déballé gagné
un pari avec un ami julien fargeau tu
connais en fait on a parié sur qui a
causé le moins que l'autre alors le tt
mathématicien ok moi mais en fait ils
juraient que il jurait que j'aurais côté
puisque lui et qu on ne jurait qu'il
aurait causé puisque moi parce qu'en
fait lui il est pas en informatique moi
je suis censé être en informatique et
finale et même même lui l'avait connaît
plus que moi à ta dernière fois où j'ai
vraiment côté j'avais 8 ans puis
d'obliger plus jamais connu ouais je
t'aime des trucs sur les ordinateurs
afin pas vraiment en pleine figure des
cris de je pense que je suis toujours
physicien en fait je fais toujours la
physique donc des physiciens c'est le
jeu
vois tu je me je ne me considère pas
comme informaticien je suis fraudé ses
chances et on peut recommencer encore un
peu plus en avant donc question des
études a commencé j'ai fait des études
de l'école marocaine en fait au maroc
j'ai fait un bac marocain et puis j'ai
fait un cursus qui ressemble à beaucoup
prépare française mais au maroc dans le
système marocain et un truc qui
ressemble encore préparer la fête c'est
un legs que des traitements et puis
après j'ai passé les concours suivi en
france
j'ai passé en fait on peut depuis ce
cursus là on peut aussi on est un tout
s'ils ont un peu autodidacte et qu'on
est moins bien bossé seul on peut passer
les concours français et allait elle en
france donc ce que j'ai fait et puis je
suis venu à l'x à polytechnique
c'est là où on a étudié ensemble au
niveau de l'hexagone
et ouais en fait ouais j'ai fait plutôt
d'un physique en fait quand j'étais à
l'x j'aime bien la physique je pensais
que je pense que l'école les codes
européennes asiatiques africaines je
pense que beaucoup de gens sympas à part
les américains au xxème siècle toutes
les écoles du monde nous voyait le monde
que à travers la matière et l'énergie
pensait qu'en fait pour comprendre le
monde faut être physicien et politiciens
font maîtriser la matière et l'énergie
la physique et ans passés à côté de
l'information
je pense que c'est pas assez valorisés
ouais je pense qu'en fait même moi j'ai
un genre quand tu te disais informatique
à 10 ans je voyais du java et c++ et de
la part des gens qui voient du world et
du coin ou dues aux halles pour moi
l'informatique cd ordinateurs et truc
qui bug il faut être faut être bien
organisée programmée tout ce que j'aime
pas moi je suis plutôt quelqu'un qui
aime l'abstraction et les maths je pense
moi plus par un flemmard disque par par
qualité quand on est flemmards on aime
bien la limmat l'abstraction la physique
théorique
et mais en fait j'ai voilà le temps que
dans ce cursus là je trouve qu'en
d'ailleurs gérard berry l'audi beaucoup
mieux que moi par exemple parlant de la
france si on parle de la france pas la
france est un pays de saint pé i de
l'énergie de la matière déjà pays minier
et puis dans cette dans cette
classification non dit des disciplines
c'est le comble de la compréhension
c'est comprendre la physique la matière
et énergie mais mais mais pas
l'information
voilà ils ont ils ont juste raté ils ont
raté ce virage alors que l'information
c'est quelque chose de très physique
attention quelque chose de très physique
qui n'a rien à voir les ordinateurs en
fait d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est pour
ça que finalement je me suis résolu à
faire un test et en informatique parce
que avec les outils conceptuels de
l'informatique
on peut aujourd'hui comprend dans la
biologie l'intelligence les
neurosciences même certains problèmes de
société en fait on peut les voir et que
nantes il loupe et algorithmique mais tu
peux donner des exemples de nourriture
discipline leur physique qu'est ce qui
serait lié à l'information
je pense comme moi ce qui m'a le plus
sensibilisés à la puissance
d'information c'est l'expérience de
pensée du démon de maxwell
je pense que si on avait expliqué le
démon de maxwell plus tôt j'aurais été
informaticien plus tôt dans ma vie
qu'est ce que tu peux expliquer quoi
louis maxwell c1 c'est donc ce suppose
en supposant comme jeu comme je pensais
ya ou comme beaucoup de personnes je
pense que beaucoup de personnes ne se
rendent pas compte que l'information
n'est pas juste quelque chose de gratuit
sera pas de soi et ses sections suppose
que l'information est gratuite on peut
imaginer un dément qui a accès à
l'information de manière gratuite
composent entre deux chambres et donc
comme la formation est gratuite et se
demandent peut voir les particules et
connaître leur vitesse et leur position
et prédire leur arrivée vers une petite
porte imaginaire il peut ouvrir la porte
quand une particule vie rapide face de
gauche à droite fermé la porte
quand une particule ans tu veux passer
de gauche à droite et ouvrir la porte
quand une particule nantes veut passer
de droite à gauche et fermer la porte
vers ces particules rapide passé de
droite à gauche ou au bout d'un moment
il aura isoler les particules rapide à
droite les particules lanta gauche est
ce qui lui permettra de générer de
l'énergie en faisant décoller le gaz
ouvert le garde fou gaz froid comme on
l'apprend en thermodynamique ou bas
comme en fait dans les pompes à chaleur
donné alors qu'en fait dans les mômes à
mal les moteurs thermiques gentil donc
en fait si l'information était gratuite
l'énergie serait gratuite or l'énergie
n'est pas gratuite donc la formation
n'est pas gratuite mais pas je simplifie
à l'extrême mais c'est un exemple
c'est le premier exemple qui m'a permis
de me rendre compte que l'information
c'est un truc très très très très
physique
vu que si on l'avait de manière gratuite
on aurait de l'énergie de manière
gratuite on peut le show fait ce qu'on
veut et faire bouger ce qu'ont donc
l'information n'est pas gratuite donc
c'est quelque chose de fondamentalement
physique juste pour préciser un peu déçu
quand tu parles d'informer et de
d'énergie elle sait pas de l'énergie qui
crée c'est juste de l'énergie qui
utilisent utile louiseville et aussi on
isole le chaud et le froid de deux côtés
c'est pareil on peut faire tourner un
moteur c'est ça c'est utile sauf qu'on
ne peut pas tourner un moteur juste en
étant bien informée si on est bien
informé on peut tourner un moteur c'est
ça se prouve le paiement de max ouais
c'est ça qui est assez étrange c'est que
ben fait l'énergie qui nous intéresse ce
parent s appelait les xerfi c'est cet
exercice qui peut être utilisé pour
faire du travail
deux applications en fait celle là elle
serait gratuite si l'information était
gratuite à peu près c'est un peu ce que
ça peu ce à quoi sensibilise
l'expérience de pensée du démon de
maxwell et et là on voit qu'on va vous
fait passer un premier exemple on voit
que on peut parler d'information sans
parler d'ordinateurs et je pense que la
forme à nos fans avant à l'informatique
comme comme comme domaine c'est un miss
nos moeurs parce que quand tu dis
informatique dans la rue les gens qui te
propose de réparer leurs ordinateurs
beaucoup pensent que tu serais pas
capable de réparer l'ordinateur sauf que
c'est pas du tout ce que je suis capable
je suis absolument incompétent pour
réparer ou même pour programmer jusqu'à
présent 1 mm hers
je pense que le mot est pas si mal
puisque séance d'information enfin ce
que ce corps ce que l'on comprenne ce
que encontre n la majorité des gens y
compris dans les milieux académiques y
compris un magicien mes collègues mais
comme mes collègues physiciens j'ai
travaillé dans un laboratoire de
physique avant de commencer ma thèse et
quand je les ai rencontrés quand je n'ai
rencontré quelques-uns je leur ai dit
finalement j'ai commencé une thèse alors
dans quoi bon en informatique qu'ils ont
rigolé parce que j'étais la dernière
personne qui aimait faire quelque chose
qu'ils avaient un rapport avec
l'ordinateur dans le labo de physique
mais il fait chaud ordinateur ni n'ai
pas besoin de toucher aux ordinateurs
les recherches là l'information c'est
que je sache c'est un objet donc d'un
conte avant donc en fait si on veut
simplifier à fait là l'humanité
progresse à chaque fois qu'elle arrive à
mettre un chiffre sur un objet qui fait
qu'ils étaient 2 qui était du ressort de
la philosophie
si on regarde l'histoire le jour où on a
mis un chiffre sur la température par
exemple
bonjour on a inventé internet c'était
une grande révolution
d'ailleurs il ya des récits de du 15e
siècle je crois avec des gens très
brillants que fibonacci où galilée jeu
là où l'autre qui rigolaient à l'idée de
mettre un chiffre sur la température
disais mais là je paraphrase jeu mais je
caricature mais je pense que la station
va dans le sens à peu près où
le savons disait quelles idées naïves de
vouloir mettre un chiffre ou une valeur
objectif sur un ressenti aussi subjectif
que le chaud et le froid
ouais donc jusqu'au 15ème siècle des
gens très brillants voyez ça comme une
chimère de vouloir mettre un chiffre sur
la température
le jour où on a mis des chiffres sur les
surfaces et les longueurs alalala
l'humanité a beaucoup progressé on a eu
des premiers empires les civilisations
commencé à s'organiser le jour en ami
donc j'ai pensé je parlais de
l'atlantique la température le jour où
un ami des chiffres exacts sur les
masses pareil le jour on a mis des
chiffres exacts sur cette chose bizarre
qui nous permet de faire bouger les
objets énergie l'appareil on a progressé
et est en fête le vingtième siècle
c'était le siècle où on allait commencer
à faire mettre un chiffre sur cet objet
abstrait qu'est l'information
mais qu'est ce que vous faites
maintenant peut donner des chiffres à
l'information
si je te donne un message ce message j
enlève de temps d'incertitude où tu
enlèves de tas de ton ignorance
si je veux te donne un autre message qui
ne t'enlève rien de temps ignorant s'il
ne t'apporte aucune information on peut
mesurer ça et c'était un progrès
significatif et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il est il est important je pense dans
les cursus de physique de faire une
réforme est de construire la physique
autour d'une trinité énergie matières
informations au lieu de la dualité
matière informations je trouve que les
cursus de physique centre est binaire
matière informations bien sûr position
ou non etc
mais ça tourne autour de la matière
d'information la matière et la voilà sa
position voilà sa vitesse voilà
l'énergie qui lui permet d'acquérir
cette vitesse etc et on laisse entendre
et on laisse en laisse les étudiants en
tout cas c'est ce qui m'est arrivé
pensait que la connaissance de cette
position et cette vitesse va de soi
c'est gratuit et je pense qu'il est très
important aujourd'hui de réformer les
cursus de physique qui deviennent
en fait que quoi que ce soit que des
cursus centré autour de l'énergie de
l'entière mais autour de cette trinité
énergie et matière d'information quand
il dit en formation dispensée à quoi
puisque j'ai l'impression tu parles
antipodes attire une information de chez
nous n'avons même pas besoin pas les
hôtesses n'ont pas besoin de parler de
l'intérêt d'information de shannon j'ai
dit chiffres jeudi tout à leur avantage
et une thèse la paire ma thèse c'est que
l'humanité progresse quand elle met des
chiffres je pense que c'est un travail
il me fait bien qui a donné le mot
algorithme qui avait dit ça je pense que
dans un de ses écrits
alors ce soit lui soit ses frères parce
qu'en fait ce qu'on dit pas ce qui est
une fratrie à travaux lis bien facile
c'était 3 les ballons moussa ils étaient
trois on en retient que voilà exemple
travailler ni le principal celui qui a
créé ce qu'ils voient là le créateur de
l'algèbre de l'algorithmique mais en
fait il avait deux frères il était une
fratrie de trois et les deux autres
avaient beaucoup de traiter de mécanique
de fabriquer les petites machines qui
ont encore remonté à la main pour faire
de la musique automatique
il avait des traités de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler aujourd'hui de
l'automatisme et un des trois
probablement moussa a dit en fait à
chaque fois que je regarde ce que les
gens veulent vraiment savoir quand ils
veulent parler objectivement de quelque
chose je fini par conclure que c'est un
chiffre et je sais pas la citation
exacte n'était pas passé en gros il
faisait en fait je pense qu'il avait
fait face à une résistance quand il a
sorti centre était donc peut-être un peu
de contexte
donc non ça c'était un juriste travail
et demi c'est un juriste et à la
différence des autres juristes
ils ne réussissaient tout les caisses
tous les tous les cas de d'héritage
qu'on lui soumettait
et jusqu'ici nation dans l'histoire
c'est l'histoire est un peu plus
compliqué que ça mais on va dire qu'il
donc d'un héritage et sunnites la
canette dans l'héritage islamique à
l'époque en fait fait l'héritage tout
court au fur et à mesure que la société
la société la civilisation progresser
avec l'écriture et la complexification
les noix de l'héritage se complexifier
et l'héritage islamique était un
incrément dans ce sens avec beaucoup de
complications la surdouée hérité la
moitié du frère là je sais pas moi
l'oncle doit hériter le huitième du père
et cetera il ya beaucoup de fraction est
en fait introniser me réussissait à
résoudre les cas d'héritage
et quand les autres juges venaient voir
la solution d'un travail et demi il
vérifier que ça collait aux lois
effectivement et long qu'il a vraiment
le sésime du père
ah ouais la mère est là le huitième du
fils ah ouais ça colle bien donc en fait
là les informaticiens de l'audience en
déjà vu un peu si on va très loin pmp
vérifier un prof vérifier une solution
averses se trouver une solution donc les
autres juges arrivé à vérifier la
solution de travaillisme mais il
n'arrivait pas à trouver par eux-mêmes
en fait ce que faisait les autres juste
c'était du tâtonnement il faisait part
pour le frère une parte pour la mer et
qui disait jusqu'à juste etc
il est fait il faisait des itérations
jusqu'à ce que ça collait à peu près aux
règles alors que crysis mais il ay
l'arrivée du premier coup avec la
solution on appellerait aujourd'hui une
clause points donc il arrivait avec la
solution est le roi de l'époque le
khalife de l'époque il a gentiment
demandé d'écrire un livre pour expliquer
aux autres juges
comment lui il arrivait à à ses
solutions bien sûr je simplifie
l'histoire la jeunesse de l'algèbre mais
la jeunesse de la grc à peu près ça il
fait halte à all is me qui savait
résoudre des problèmes qui va écrire un
livre de recettes pour que d'autres
juges puissent aussi résoudre ces
problèmes
sans être aussi intelligent 4 à aubigny
ouais donc une analyse me va sur un
livre externaliser son intelligence et
la mettre à disposition des autres juges
sous forme de
recette mais tout comme aujourd'hui je
suis nul en pâtisserie je peux
télécharger une recette de la tarte au
citron et là je fabrique une tarte au
citron sans avoir été capable d'inventer
la tarte au citron
donc en fait il a donc il a créé une le
seul livre de recettes et je sais plus
quel historien disais donc en fait à
l'époque
bon ça choque pas besoin d'eux pas
besoin d'aller vers l'histoire
aujourd'hui ça choque les gens les gens
ont tendance à je pensais même à tout
moment se reconnaître les gens remet la
vie c'est pas des maths
donc imaginez vous étant être abolie
semis au huitième ou neuvième siècle
vous sortez un livre d'algèbre vous
formulez des recettes capable de
résoudre des cas d'héritage ou en sépare
des terrains agricoles et puis quelqu'un
de la société vous dire oui mais moi je
veux diviser des chèvres tu vas te dire
que ton bouquin qui divise de surface va
m'aider à l'elysée des chaires et en
fait je pense que c'est dans ce contexte
là qu'il faut comprendre la réponse de
travail et demi où il disait à chaque
fois que les gens veulent eux m veut une
connaissance objective je ne trouve rien
de mieux qu'un chiffre c'est d'elle que
c'est la citation exacte va dans ce sens
si en gros quand on veut objective ans
quand on veut répondre objectivement
kankankan les gens veulent savoir je ne
trouve rien de mieux qu'un chiffre c'est
une citation d'un des frères banos
moussa soit 2 à 3 me soit de ses deux
frères et on verrait presque une proto
[Musique]
c'est un proto 2 ps2 calculabilité en
fait en ne peut objectivement les choses
qu'avec des chiffres et est donc
pourquoi je parle tout ça je disais
l'aller on peut lire l'histoire humaine
à travers ce prisme là au moins
l'histoire de la civilisation humaine
post écriture le prisme du progrès par
les chiffres
non on peut voir les époques et à chaque
époque on va trouver que il ya eu une
grandeur qui a été chiffre qui a été
objective et la température les sur
fallait d'abord les d'abord les
distances très très présente donc des
distances
enfin avant les distances et chèvres les
chèvres et les chèvres et les parts de
blé est d'ailleurs l'invention de
l'écriture donc la majorité des tables
sumérienne en fait c'est intel a donné
trois oeuvres intel qui lui a rendu
trois trucs de blé qui lui a rendu 5
mesure de juste par georges versus
quatre chèvres et de moutons
donc on ad'abord objective et les biens
agricoles avec des nombres puis après
les distances et commencer à mesurer la
surface puis petit à petit le nombre de
choses qui relevait du spirituel et du
métaphysique diminué et le nombre de
choses qui commencent à être chiffrée
par la physique et les mathématiques a
augmenté et en fait on peut voir le
progrès humain comme ça et aujourd'hui
des gens ont du mal avec le fait de
chiffres et l'information
par exemple une fois je discutais avec
un ami
sociologue je disais les problèmes ne se
valent pas les problèmes en sociologie
ne viens pas dit non chaque problème à
ses spécificités mais donc lui disais ce
problème a ses spécificités et ses tu ne
peux pas me dire qu'il ya une échelle de
difficulté des problèmes du genoa
si si il a une échelle on peut
quantifier au moins mettre des bornes
supérieur ou déborde inférieur sur la
difficulté des problèmes étudier la
grille salariale des trader à la city
c'est un problème plus difficile que tu
dis est la grille salariale due
des fonctionnaires la france est parce
que la grille salariale des
fonctionnaires et les fixes et les
gradués sur des échelles bien connu et
il suffit de connaître tant d'ancienneté
ton diplôme deux années d'études et
c'est un nombre fini alors là déjà en
parle devant un nombre fini de deux
variables pour prédire tant salaires
alors que trader à la city
ça va dépendre de recruter avant la
crise ou après la crise ayant un master
en truitelles ou pas la variabilité des
salaires la difficulté des problèmes
hélas il était d'accord il était
d'accord que je disais juste combien
d'années il te faudrait quant au combien
d'interviews de trader à la city tout
faudrait pour faire 1 une sociologie des
salaires à la city et combien de salaire
de fonctionnaire surtout surtout si on
restera le chan d'y aller les salaires
des thésards du cnrs
c'est simple il ya trois ou quatre
niveaux de salaires et traders de la
city à plusieurs niveaux de salaires est
l'objet intellectuelle qui va nous
mettre d'accord - et c'est amis c'est
quoi c'est un chiffre ne prend bien il
te faut d'échantillons et là là on
tourne autour du pot en fait combien il
te faut c'est ce que les informaticiens
vont appeler ça un peu complexe et y
donc la complexité d'échantillonnage
combien il faut d'échantillons pour pour
conclure à tel ou tel modèle est donc le
xxème siècle je reviendrai je disais je
sus physicien latéral peut-être jusqu'à
ce que la dette a parlé d'un truc en
sociologie mes écrits intriguant c'est
sûr que non avec un autre avis car ça
fait avec une autre personne qui
beaucoup plus âgé et expérimenté que la
vie dont je parlais d'une heure ouais on
a un petit
[Musique]
on a créé un papier ensemble
d'épistémologie qui essaie de faire ce
travail là en fait de sensibiliser une
audience de sciences sociales à la
science de la complexité et si on veut
bien revenir à eau mm isner de
l'informatique le commun des mortels et
malheureusement même dans le monde
académique me retiens l'aromatique
l'ordinateur mais en fait l'apport le
plus important de l'informatique à la
civilisation humaine
il est conceptuel c'est la théorie de la
corse et c'est le fait d' objectivité
cette chose qui était très mal formulées
avant qui était qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qu'être difficile qu'est ce qu'être
facile qu est ce qui est très difficile
qu'elle qu'est ce qu'être complexe
est-ce qu'on peut mettre les chiffres
dessus pour arrêter de croire que c'est
en sortant on se rappelle de ceux ci ont
rappelé tout à l'heure j'ai mentionné le
physicien du 15e siècle qui se moquaient
d'eux l'idée de mettre des chiffres sur
des ressenti subjectif du chaud et du
froid
aujourd'hui ça choque plus personne
qu'on à l'échelle ci dessus c'est une
échelle cubains qui sont très objectif
pas pareil le plus grand apport de
l'algorithme et de l'informatique au 20e
siècle
c'est de chlore ou au moins
partiellement clore ce débat que les
problèmes ne se valent
il y à des échelles de complexité il ya
des problèmes plus difficiles que
d'autres
certains problèmes ont besoin de plus
d'échantillons donc il ya le coup en
échantillons certains problèmes en
besoin de plus de temps pour être
résolus il faut faire plus de calculs il
faut faire plus d'états de raisonnement
oublions nos calculs puisque les gens
sont dérangés par le terme calcul il
faut raisonner plus longuement pour
conclure que sur un problème est certes
un certain non placent de problèmes
requiert plus d espace pendant que je
raisonne il faut que je stocke les
données intermédiaires au mes
conclusions partielles et certains
problèmes requiert plus d'espacé que
d'autres et donc l'informatique est là
et là haut et l'arrondi objectif ce
ressenti de difficultés en fait les
matins
mais mal et mathématicien avait ce
ressenti avant mais il croyait que voilà
on n'est juste pas ou pas suffisamment
bon en fait les problèmes non résolus
c'est juste parce que l'humanité n'ait
pas encore bonne fin de citation de
gilberte nous devons savoir nous allons
savoir en fait le plus grand apport de
l'informatique c'est une réponse
négative à ce set
cette conjecture et une verte que nous
devons savoir nous allons savoir non il
ya des choses qu'on ne voit jamais
savoir
et dans le second set dans le
sous-ensemble des choses qu'on peut
savoir
il ya des choses qui peuvent se savoir
plus facilement que d'autres
c'est peut-être juste pour clarifier un
peu des potées provost donc tu parles de
de parler beaucoup d'informations ont
fait état aussi pas mal parlé s'en sont
peut-être le dire du traitement de
l'information qui est une énorme partie
en fait de telles informations de la rue
du calcul ce que prend fin la théorie du
calcul en fait c'est la manipulation de
l'information exacte
moi j'aimerais moi j'aimerais bien
renommée l'informatique en fait si on
veut bien la renommée il ya deux
candidats c'est épistémologie
quantitatif je pense qu'il ya aussi des
gens comme scott harrison qui emportait
ce terme et où alors science du faisable
enfin mais un peu quand on veut on peut
dire que l'informatique aujourd'hui
c'est la science du faisable de
l'existant et de la prenable mais en
fait c'est tous des sous des sous
ensembles baroques et redire social pour
moi je parle d'algorithmique oui de
paraître de l'informatique j'ai tendance
à paris + d'algorithmique presque en
algorithmes c'est quoi c'est un
traitement d'informations que donc c'est
plus mettre l'accent sur le traitement
d'informations que sur l'information en
tant que tel même si les deux sont très
intéressants en tant que tel après tout
apparaît du coup de la science du
faisable qu'est ce que tu entends par là
c'est ça peut paraître surprenant pour
ces camps est la science de faisable
donc revenons à cette chimère
mathématique non constructive jusqu'au
19ème siècle donc d'utiliser tout à
l'heure en fait
ou quand on est au collège et au lycée
on a cette impression que en fait pour
tout problème et une réponse y compris
l'ensemble vide ya pas de solution c'est
des réponses et comme on n'est juste pas
suffisamment banc et qu'on va finir par
savoir c'est une conjecture de gilberte
c'est sûr que
toute question à une réponse et
l'informatique n'est pas né du désir de
fabriquer des meilleurs macbook
l'informatique est né du désir de
répondre à cette conjecture de gilberte
mais est ce que toute question à une
réponse pour répondre à cette conjecture
alan turing le fondateur de
l'informatique moderne va d'abord
formaliser ce que c'est que répondre
mais donc répondre c'est faire le
travail des travailleuses me créer une
recette permettant à toute personne de
retrouver la réponse ouais donc créer
une recette
bah en fait sous-entendu il est finie en
fait la recette
elle s'exécute je peux l'écrire sur un
papier et de la donner
la guerre est finie donc créer une
recette philly qui permet à toute
personne en un temps fini de pouvoir
répondre et pour montrer que ceci n'est
pas possible pour toutes les questions à
la tuerie il va exhiber un premier
contre exemples bien un problème de
l'arrêt donc tu peux le décrire
décrivant le problème de la rai qui est
cliquée vraiment je pense lefa l'un des
plus beaux théorème de l'histoire des
mathématiques
c'est un excellent client lui ont crié
les il écrit donc étant donnée la
question suivante les je suis ministre
de la fonction publique france fonction
publique en france ça commence bien
je veux que tu m'écrivent une procédure
ne permettant d'auditer le
fonctionnement de mes fonctionnaires
pour chercher si à des moments donnés
les citoyens ne risque pas de faire des
boucles infini en fait à faire des
allers-retours interminables sans jamais
avoir leurs papiers ou leurs documents
ou ou leur autorisation de monter une
boîte ce qui en fut à faire à la
bureaucratie en souvent que lui ce
problème de vos bureaux douze demandes
le document à revient au bureau 13
imprime le document c'est légalise le
document c
donne lieu au bureau avant un délai de
trois mois sauf que la légalisation a
duré trois mois
rebelote il faut recommencer donc si par
exemple je crée une procédure
administrative ou un délai de
l'égalisation d'un document est
supérieur au taux aux exigences aux
exigences du bureau donné le citoyen
n'aura jamais ce qu'il irait donc moi je
suis ministre et je veux toile et je
veux tout mathématicien très fort je
veux que tu m'écrivent une procédure qui
me permettra d'audit et mon
administration publique trt et n va
auditer des procédures est ce qu'il
existe une procédure qui audite les
procédures est épatant diatta on va
juste audités on peut ceci est valable
pour l'administration publique les
années 50 papiers stylos pas besoin
d'ordinateur pas besoin d'inventer
d'invoquer quoi que ce soit
l'informatique au sens commun pour
comprendre le problème de la donc est ce
que les tu peux écrire et procédure qui
va auditer les procédures et dire si
elle termine ou pas ainsi les citoyens
français auront ce qu'ils veulent dans
un temps fini avant la fin du monde
ouais et turing va utiliser un classique
de l'époque donc en fait la fin du 19e
siècle va connaître un classique en
matin technique assez élégante en
mathématiques
initié par condor pire c'est l'argument
diagonale donc c'est le troll ultime
hommage
c'est très élégant pour ceux qui
connaissent pas l'histoire de russell
c'est vraiment le troll le plus
dévastateur
pascal troll bloc thürig 20 sens donc
pour moi les 30 les 30 ans qui ont suivi
donc la fin du 19e siècle jusqu'aux
années 30
c'étaient les trois décennies de
l'argument diagonale et donc arrive
l'argument des gaules un ultime celui
turing supposant qu'il existe une
procédure je vais l'appeler h
il ya une vidéo il ya une excellente
vidéo en dida parachute sur problème de
la reine l'indécidabilité donc supposant
qu'il existe une procédure je vais
l'appeler h pour rallier qui vit en
entrée une autre procédure je vais
l'appeler rare pour algorithmes
et qui donne un camp à termine à 0 quand
elle ne termine pas mais si elle existe
j'ai le droit de construire une autre
procédure je vais l'appeler h par tel
que caen hb sort 1 h bar entre en boucle
infinie
je peux écrire ça hhk et définit ainsi
quand tu vois que h à dire oui toi
entrée en doute l'infini quand tu vois
que h à dinan d'inwi et je ne fais je
vais donner aschbach h
je veux dire 'ah audit mois h par et
c'est facile de se convaincre vous
pouvez aller voir sur la vidéo en aide a
que 6 h existe alors h ne peut pas
audités h par enfin on ne peut pas
terminer ne peut pas dire en un temps
finit 6 h var termine donc en fait tu en
viens en supposant l'existence de
procédures qui auditent toutes les
procédures
on peut construire une autre procédure
qui elle troll la procédure m c'est un
peu comme russell trop l'ultime de
russell de l'ensemble de tous les
ensembles et donc en fait turing c'est
chemin faisant
en fait voilà voilà l'objectif de
turenne l'objectif de turing c'était de
répondre à isbergues de répondre à quoi
viennent dans les gares de verdun une
personne vers 21h50 étoiles
nous allons savoir nous devons
maintenant nous devons nous allons
savoir nous allons savoir 2 on savoir
comment en fait maintenant c'est
l'inversé
voilà ça nous devons savoir nous alors
c'est vrai tu règles la réponse de
turing non nous n'allons pas tout savoir
et j'arrête tout de suite les
relativistes de l'audience ceci n'est
pas une négation du formalisme
mathématique non non alors je j'arrive
tout de suite ce qu'ils vont voir
relativisme
ah ah ah d'accord donc en fait rien
n'est absolu nous allons rien à voir
mais non en fait c'est très important de
cerner ce que on ne peut pas savoir pour
pouvoir de d'isoler ce qu'on ne peut pas
savoir pour pouvoir bien comprendre ce
que nous pouvons savoir et donc turing
va répondre voici un problème pour
lequel nous n'allons jamais avoir une
réponse sous forme de recettes qui
termine en un temps finis et chemin
faisant il a montré que sans abstraction
sans objet abstrait qui résout les
problèmes avec une procédure itérative
et c est en fait une et universelle dans
le sens où s'il existe toute autre
procédure permettant de répondre aux
problèmes décida donc aux problèmes qui
ne tombe pas sous le règne de la résine
problème de la règle il sera similaire
équivalent à la machine de thierry qu'en
fait la machine de turing c'est un sorte
de c'était une sorte de bonus ce n'était
pas l'objectif c'est vraiment important
d'enseigner ça en fait je pense que je
disais tout à l'heure
moi j'ai beaucoup sur le secteur de
l'éducation j'aimerais bien qu'on en
rajoute un peu plus d'informations dans
les cursus de physique et surtout quand
on ajoute un peu plus d'histoire des
sciences dans l'enseignement des
sciences c'est vraiment important de
savoir comment on en est arrivé là
comment en fait l'informatique et
l'informatique est né d'un désir de
répondre à une question purement
philosophique aurait pas d' un désir de
r&d de d'amélioration des calculettes
dalibard soit tu te rappelles jandali va
on avait un prof alix qui est les gens
dalibard était aujourd'hui à l'académie
des sciences je crois et au collège de
france et il disait le laser n'a pas été
inventé par des consultants à qui on a
demandé d'améliorer les outils de chez
roche
c'est un peu pareil la machine de turing
n'a pas été inventé par quelqu'un à qui
on a demandé d'améliorer les
calculatrices
mais c'était une invention c'était un
bonus d'une réponse à une question
purement philosophique qui est est ce
que toutes questions et réponses chemin
faisant l'inventaire la machine de
turing est en a initié ce qui va être
après la science du faisable donc
maintenant quand c'est qu'il ya des
questions pour lesquelles n'y a pas de
réponse
on peut s'amuser à classifier les
questions pour lequel il ya des réponses
alors il y aura on va pour montrer qu'il
ya des problèmes pour lesquels on peut
avoir une réponse en 10 minutes et des
problèmes pour lesquels on aura des
réponses en l'imminuté des problèmes
pour lesquels on a des réponses sont les
fractions de seconde et des problèmes
pour lesquels on aura des réponses
seront mis en milan 3 milan n'a juste
pour insister encore un peu plus sur la
machine de turing est ce qu'il ya un
autre truc qui est assez remarquable
avec la machine de turing c'est que
c'est un fait pourquoi ce qui c'est une
machine parce que tu aurais je voulais
un truc mécanique un truc qui qu'ils
soient vraiment faisable font vraiment
un truc mécanique on peut mettre ça
devant toi mais tu as well as pas
construite immédiatement universel mais
bois il avait enfin preuve de concept
qui était et puis en plus qu assez
incroyable c'est que non seulement il
construit une machine mais il montre en
plus quelle machine est universel donc
c'est vraiment la science du faisable en
ce sens exactement exactement dans quoi
en fait est le premier mot c'est
faisable et en fait en entre là on va
arrêter de parler au nom de turing
l'histoire ne pas dire ce qu'il n'a pas
dit ce qu'on va parler de ce qu'on
appelle la thèse de physique de zürich
turing mais en fait c'est un peu des
choses qu on s sur la bouche tout sur
schering turing mes règles que les gones
n'ont pas vraiment on va parler du de
l'existant et de la probable ouais bon
puisqu'elle a été sur turing il est
plusieurs versions de cette thèse on est
sûrs futur ils ont quand même défendu
des versions très physique
ouais je pense assez physiquement déjà
des versions un peu plus sur réseaux
fixes déjà sur qu'est-ce que ce cas la
question c'est qu'est ce que vend une
seule action qu'est ce qui est faisable
est ce que répond de churchill turing
c'est que ce qui est faisable ce sont
les algorithmes défini par machine de
turing est l'homme des calculs de t
shirts du xi ses rangs un truc peut-être
un peu philosophique mais vraiment
physique finalement c'est qu'est ce qui
est faisable
en fait on peut dès qu'on accepte cette
thèse on peut tout de suite
[Musique]
allez allez à l'étape suivante à dire
qu'est ce que l'existant ouais et on
peut dire qu'il existe enquête pourquoi
j'existe j'existe parce que il ya eu
procédure chimiques qui m'a fabriqué il
ya eu une série de réactions chimiques
entre ça et ça et ça et qui ont donné la
vie et puis la vie a évolué et cetera
puis après des reptiles puis des manifs
air puis etc à des singes des grands
singes puis jusqu'aux hominidés jusque
jusqu'à notre petite personne ici dans
ses ouailles toi dans ces podcasts
il ya une procédure qui en un temps fini
nous a fabriqué et en fait l'existence
et un sous-ensemble de faisable on peut
remarquer que le faisable et plus grand
plus existant parce que il ya des chose
faisable qu'on va pas fabriqué il existe
il existe des machines capables et or il
existe des logiciels capables de
supprimer tout ce que tout ce qui est
tout ce qu'il ya sur votre disque dur
mais on va pas s'amuser à les produire
parce que ça va nuire à la société
il existe je sais pas - il existe des
vélos il existe des vélos tels qu' il
existe un vélo tels que si je quand la
personne pédales et un marteau qui lui
cogne le franc on va pas s'amuser à le
fabriquer il existe pas pourquoi il
existe parce que je peux te décrire une
procédure voilà le vélo tu mets des
pédales tülin de [ __ ] à une croix la
courroie actionne une manivelle qui fait
tourner le marteau qui tape le
conducteur donc voilà un objet faisable
et quand on va pas fabriquer on va on
peut se mettre d'accord que l'existence
et 1 500 en sous-entendus finale toi
donc soit les tu existes j'existe part
qu' il ya eu deux parents qui se sont
mis ensemble qui ont donné un foetus qui
a suivi une série de réactions chimiques
qui a donné un bébé qui a grandi qui a
donné des idées existent parce que il ya
eu une série de réactions chimiques de
neurotransmetteurs qui s'en passer dans
tes dents des synapses et cetera pour
que tu m'invites à ce podcast donc sans
invitation à ce podcast existe parce
qu'elle est le résultat d'une procédure
faisable mais en importe qui est
derrière ça on voit un peu à désirer tu
parles d'un produit assez
physique mais il ya la question s'il a
moins de mathématiques est ce que
l'existence d'un objet est ce que ça
doit être le résultat d'une procédure et
les gens qui pensent à ce qu'on appelle
les mathématiciens constructiviste ils
se posent aux mathématiques classique ou
matériel classique on hamm est souvent
l'existence d' objets qui sont pas
calculable qui sont pas le résultat
d'une procédure simple fait un peu c'est
marrant que ce débat ne soit pas au
moins chez les physiciens fait ça serait
il est grand temps que les physiciens
tranche ici en berne je pense que en
termes mathématiques je ne je ne
pourrais pas du tout conclure mais au
moins tu es un physique
je pense que tout comme on a conclu que
la seule physique qu'on puisse faire
dans ce monde si bas c'est la physique
de la matière qui se conserve et de
l'énergie qui se conservent le seul
traitement de l'information qu'on puisse
faire dans ce monde si bas c'est le
traitement de l'information qui conclut
en un temps fini mais la réponse
physique à ce débat et les tranchées
vers le constructivisme
mais mathématiquement au plus je pense
que je pense qu'il est bien pour la
société de laisser une fraction des
mathématiciens s'amuser sur prêts nous
les maintenons constructives sont belles
aussi oui bien sûr et les outils aussi
très utile utile pour avoir une idée
mais
mais maintenant si on fait des filles
ont fait les matons constructive on va
tomber sur des théorèmes qui vont dire
l'existence d'un objet qu'on peut pas
construire en tout cas pour faire de la
science
personnellement moi ce qui m'intéresse
dans cette ville c'est la philosophie de
la nature
je dis ça en français nacho philosophie
donc les signes de l'âge les sciences
naturelles et dans le contexte restreint
des sciences naturelles
donc ce qui m'intéresse dans les maths
c'est les mains constructive parce que
c'est celle qui me permettent de
comprendre l'existant que le faisable et
l'existant et la prenable et donc que le
don qui capte le dernier os était
imprenable c'est ça ouais existe en
l'apprenant peut développer ce que
j'entends par est prenable en fait un
autre ensemble de l'existence et la
pratique oui c'est donc un vélo un vélo
il ya un marteau qui tape le conducteur
sahara c'est un objet faisable nerfs
pour autant il n'est pas existant parce
que personne n'a envie de conduire un
vélo qui lui tape le crâne à chaque coup
de [ __ ] et un autre sous ensembles de
les manquer donc l'existant est un
sous-ensemble de du faisable
la preuve nabeul est un autre sous
ensembles du faisable n'est donc
j'apprends
quand j'apprends en cours c'est parce
que il ya eu une procédure en un temps
fini ap les cours donnés par le prof
et que j'ai suivi une procédure qui a
qui s'est exécuté en un temps finis
appelé lecture répétées du court après
quoi je suis devenu capable de répondre
aux questions de l'examen
donc les questions de l'examen sont à
prenable parce que je peux suivre une
procédure fini en un temps infini pour
avoir la connaissance en fait pour me
reconfigurer moi en tant que machine
donc mais mes synapses vont se
reconfigurer pour pouvoir répondre aux
échos question de l'examen
là encore
il n'y a rien de mystérieux dans ce
processus et c'est un processus des
quelques ont pu décrire au moins au
moins dans un cadre conceptuel par une
procédure est un algorithme traitement
d'informations un traitement de
l'information
je regarde le court je vois qu'il ya
cette phrase qui vient souvent après
cette autre phrase il ya quelque chose
de chimiques et de faisable et de fini
et qui se termine et qui se produit dans
un cerveau qui se reconfigure qui me
rend capables de regret cure jt c'est
une connaissance c'est faisable à
prenable et un autre sous ensembles du
faisable mais est d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
en fait il ya toute une science qui
s'intéressent à ce qui est imprenable
en fait et on voit très clairement que
ça ne sort pas du cadre de
l'algorithmique du faisable
on va juste s'est intéressée à combien
il faut voir d'exemple combien de temps
il faut passer à regarder ces exemples
combien de mémoire il nous faut pour
stocker les paramètres nous aidant à
prendre ces exemples c'est pour ça que
tu parles d'épistémologie quantitative
voilà voilà ce que c'est que
l'informatique nous a fallu faire tout
ce détour parce que malheureusement les
clichés sont durs et je parle de nous
deux en fait je pense que tu nous posait
la question il ya dix ans qu'est ce que
l'informatique ont cinq six ans c'est la
séance déjà là et de c++ et là
clairement il ya un panda n'est pas
utile vous en faites gino vais quitter
juste à côté et 1 x n était pas foutu
d'aller lire son livre la bêta propose
du calcul il était sorti en 2007
le livre était sorti a sorti que déjà
sorti ce qu'il était déjà il avait eu le
prix de l'académie de la gagne et
française en 2007
d'ailleurs c'est marrant parce que je
viens d'apprendre que c'était michel
serres qui a recommandé
elle sert qu'il est décédé récemment
du coup c'est ma raison de parler un
petit peu de michel serres qui est une
personne c'est remarquable je compte
très vivement une nombreuses conférences
qui a fait forte sur qui sont sur
youtube et qui notamment parler vraiment
énormément du rôle de l'information
alors que cet appareil permet de
l'information en sciences pour les
sciences dans les sciences et pour
panser les sciences et tout ça mais lui
parler de l'information comme étant un
objet central pour les civilisations que
ça c'est une autre célébrité dans ma vie
qui est moins connu que michel serres
c'est mon père qui ne sait cet été ça en
fait si on voit la grande histoire de la
vie je pense d'ailleurs ce qui m'a ce
qui m'a vraiment amené en fait ce qui
m'a amené vers la physique
personnellement c'est en fait c'est un
goût pour l'histoire
ok c'est pas clair pourquoi si on veut
faire la grande histoire la physique
pour l'histoire c'est pas l'histoire du
maroc houda civilisation islamique ou de
je ne sais pas quoi l'histoire ça
commence sa crainte avec le big bang
ça va vers la création du système
solaire de la terre la création de la
lune la stabilisation de leurs beats la
stabilisation de la kz2 rotation
terrestre les saisons l'apparition de la
vie
la colle à la complexité de la révolte
la révolution cambrienne puis
l'apparition des vertébrés puis puis des
manies faire tuer des humains depuis
l'invention du feu puis pour moi c'est
ça l'histoire c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
m'a si ce qui m'a ce qui m'a poussé vers
la physique mais en fait on peut
regarder la grande histoire de la vie au
moins de la ville
on est au moins de la houle liant la
l'histoire de l'inerte oubliant de
l'histoire du système solaire et des
plats etc
concentrons nous sur la vie la vie est
apparue là on est qui a plus ou moins
quand on sut scientifique que la ville
est apparue condé première cancon quand
on a comme quand la première phénomène
de réplication a eu lieu donc des ddt
molécule serait pic du système
permettent à des molécules de se
répliquer et en se réplique ans yvan
copier une information dont quoi en ce
recopiant ils font des bébés ont des
bébés imaginons la vie monocellulaires
des cellules se répliquent par la mito
ce qui divise en deux divise en deux
puis division divise en deux puis un
moment donné et cellules à des mutations
là encore simplifié à l'extrême des
mutations utiles lui permettant à celles
qui portent cette mutation de mieux
survivre et de mieux se dupliquer elle
va alors plus se dupliquer et donc
l'attrait de transmettre cette mutation
à nos générations suivantes
donc le substrat de transmission de
l'information c'étaient là des pans le
substrat de transmission de
l'information était que l'adn
il a fallu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
temps à la vie pour se complexifier de
l'ordre d'un milliard d'années je crois
et puis un moment donné abandonner la
dette des organismes cellulaires se sont
mis à cracher les uns sur les autres
aires la sphère union s'est pas toujours
comment les premiers organismes
multicellulaires seraient apparus mais
probablement par des par des phénomènes
soit de cannibalisme soit ce soit juste
de te moques l'espace ils se sont
rencontrés les uns sur les autres et on
a eu des organismes multicellulaires et
qui ont continué qui ont perpétué cette
manière de transmettre l'information
c'est-à-dire il ya un seul substrat
entre une génération à la suivante c'est
la d1 permet de transmettre une mutation
qui a eu de la chance d'être plus utile
un moment donné les organismes
multicellulaires ont développé le
système nerveux central système nerveux
central c'est quoi c'est en fait une
sorte de cahier encore je vais me fâcher
plein de biologistes c'est une sorte de
cahier où on va apprendre en attendant
on va éliminer les attitudes
qui ne permettait pas bien de se
reproduire et de bien manger et
renforcer les attitudes qui permettent
de mieux manger bien se reproduire et on
va faire une transmission à soi même
pendant son vécu on est passé d'une
étape où la transmission de
l'information ne se faisait que à la fin
de la vie on se fit aux en transmet au
suivant il ya aucun apprentissage au
coût de la vie en fait si maintenant on
apprend que les réseaux métabolique
apprennent aussi mais c'est un autre
sujet et puis on va complexifier le
substrat par la création d'une sorte de
gros cahier système nerveux central et c
est par la plasticité qui permet de
corriger deux fins de modifier des
paramètres et de devenir plus efficace
de long de sa vie et puis à un moment
donné ces organismes multicellulaires
encore j'accélère l'histoire la faune
vont commencer à passer du temps avec
leur bébé et non seulement leur
transmettront leurs gènes mais vont
s'occuper d'eux pendant quelques années
pour leur transmettre sorte résumé des
meilleurs dvd best of et des web
strophes de leur vécu
en gros les parents passent du temps
avec leurs enfants
pour le résumer pendant la durée de
l'enfance qui est de l'ordre de chez pas
moins trois ans pour les chimpanzés en
deux ans pour les chimpanzés maintenant
25 ans pour les humains vont leur
transmettre les bonnes choses à faire et
les mauvaises choses à ne pas faire
et donc là on accélère l'apprentissage
en fait en accélère et avantias pourquoi
parce qu'on a changé de substrats
d'apprentissage deux barres de substrats
de transmission d'informations avant il
était uniquement chimiques la vienne
maintenant il rien il est toujours
chimiques maintenant c'est pas que l'adn
c'est aussi ce qu'on va marquer dans le
cerveau de l'enfant en éduquant et puis
à un moment donné ces organismes
multicellulaires qui éduquent leurs
enfants vont développer le langage ça va
encore plus complexifiés le substrat sur
lequel on transmet d'approbation et donc
accélérer l'apprentissage collectif raie
et à un moment donné c'est ces
bizarreries
qui ont des enfants et qui leur parle
vont se mettre à écrire c'est humain et
puis en écrivant ces s'est passé pas
très récent c'est pas très anciens c'est
assez récent ses 1500 entre 1500 à peu
près 1000 mille 1000 et 2000 3000 aller
au fond d'un grand bac 5 min de l'ordre
du milan avant jésus-christ donc il ya
environ 6000 8000 année selon selon les
formes selon ce qu'on a ce cour ce camp
se consument s'accorde à appeler
écriture ils vont externalisés donc
jusqu'à l'invention de l'écriture
le substrat de transmission et de
l'informer de l'information était
interne adn système nerveux central
système nerveux cerveau d'accord puis le
système de transmission était aussi
internes voix parole
bon ok j'ai peut-être utilisé un peu
trop tôt c'est le début de
l'externalisation c'est le langage mais
amy c'est un support qui pètent pas
fiable quand guy qui dépend du corps
puisqu'elle reste pas que des kinois
légumes persiste pas le moment où on va
externaliser le support de transmission
de l'information le moment au majeur
c'est l'invention de l'écriture on va
externaliser ce suspens et on va écrire
on va écrire dans un support qui est
externe aux parents et à l'enfant et au
voisin et à tous ceux qui ont écrit et
qui peut être transmis à d'autres
groupes sociaux etc et ça va accélérer
l'apprentissage collectif
en fait la grande histoire de la vie
c'est une histoire d'accélération de
l'apprentissage collectif
ouais rythmée par quoi rythmé par des
progrès dans le substrat ou en en
transmet l'information jusqu'à ainsi
celui ci a mentionné michel serres ce
que c'est c'est bien de se rendre à
vichy serre ce qui est nécessaire
il raconte je crois il ya une conférence
qu'il donnait à l'inria et
il le racontait l'histoire de de saint
denis
ça donnait le sein oui c'est un dessin
de pas risque de choquer au début de la
chrétienneté anciens paris je pense à
pelé lutèce je crois autres comme ça les
premiers chrétiens étaient enfermés dans
une chambre fenêtres fermées etc pour
les ans élu leurs prêtres et v statut et
il leur fait donc ils étaient réunies et
puis un moment donné les légions
romaines arrive casse les fenêtres il
entre dans la salle et ils vont couper
la tête à 100 me mais la tête a du mal
avec denis et saint denis va prendre la
tête qui a roulé par terre et la 2g
comme ça et la montrer aux fidèles je
crois qu'il ya un flou qui représente
way et michel serres disait disait aux
gens viennent rien en fait ce que vous
ce qu'on a fait maintenant avec la
machine
enfin parce qu'on l'a on l'a déjà fait
avec l'écriture mais ce qu'on a fait
encore plus avec l'ordinateur fait on a
la tête en la maintenant devant nous
elle n'a plus la plus sûre au long way
comme saint denis qui porte sa tête dans
les mains
ouais et jean prendre vivement ce strict
d'ailleurs il ya d'autres choses soient
qu'elle voulait réagir c'est le
notamment michel serge président cette
conférence dans une autre maison ils
racontent souvent que une façon de
mesurer l'importance d'une nouvelle
c'est de regarder le temps à quel ça met
fin quoi et à quel point les chaussons
du coup différentes après qu une somme
pense à l'écriture l'ordre de grandeur
des civilisations humaines ans à ces 100
millions que l'os comme ça ça me fait
angoissant milan et puis puis en eau
si on regarde son bilan par rapport au
temps entre moment l'invention des
catcheurs aujourd'hui enfin le monde a
complètement changé ça ça donne un ordre
d'idée de à quel point cette invention
en particulier a vraiment bouleversé
l'état des civilisations et puis notre
agir aussi parce que tu apparais du
vivant et de l'information et je suis en
train de découper le livre de jeunes
égoïste de richard dawkins ou en fait on
écoute on truque on a vraiment
l'impression que la biologie c'est juste
une histoire de en formation qu'en salle
et surtout mais chez le prix fort avant
lisions on va dire où c'est vraiment
d'aider des jeunes qui essaient de gérer
l'information pour avoir ensuite ce que
ce que dans qu'ils appellent des
machines re a répliqué sur des individus
faire des animaux que et tout le jeu
c'est vraiment un jeu d'information
préserver l'information améliorer
l'information édité l'information
transformer l'information ainsi de suite
et ça c'est fait c'est bien que tu es
mentionné petite heure de vie comme une
histoire de transmission d'informations
et en fait il ya beaucoup aujourd'hui
donc tu m'as demandé avant l'épisode de
parler un peu de ce que je fais dans mon
travail au moins un tiers de ma thèse
porte sur des sujets biologie théorique
je m'intéresse à la robustesse en fait
la tolérance au foot dans les réseaux et
abric way est tout à l'heure j'ai triché
d'abord quand j'ai dit que peut-être les
organismes unicellulaires non pas
d'apprentissage sur l'âge et c'est plus
compliqué que ça il ya ce qu'on appelle
les raisons metabolix et c'est un peu
c'est des réseaux de réactions chimiques
où il ya des coefficients qui peuvent se
corriger s'adapter à face au faso vécu
et ce qui m'intéresse en fait moi dans
la biologie c'est comment on peut la
décrire par des abstractions de
mathématique n'est qui ont fait leurs
preuves en fait en informatique donc la
théorie des graphes
mallet l'histoire de la théorie de la
complexité en fait on peut entendre
maintenant tout comme tout comme la
méthode scientifique a apporté une
manière de lunar d'éliminer des
hypothèses
en fait la théorie de la complexité et
permet aussi d'éliminer des hypothèses
si vous avez un mycologue donc quelqu'un
qui étudie les fourmis qui vous vous dit
que les fourmis fonctionne comme ça les
fourmis fonctionne comme ça a b c d
voila voila mon modèle de fonctionnement
des fourmis en fait jusqu'au 19ème
siècle la méthode scientifique
consistait à tester empiriquement la
théorie aujourd'hui on peut en fait on
peut éliminer des hypothèses sont les
tester juste en regardant regardant leur
complexité
par exemple si quelqu'un vous dit que
les conjonctions calling for fournie
fonctionne parce que la reine dit aux
guerriers fière de dire ou au gazole et
les fours à fouad et les cueilleuses de
ramener plus de blé ben vous pouvez
faire un calcul pour lui dire que bon la
complexité de ce mode de communication
est très grande et et ce mode de
communication n'est pas tolérant à la
mort de 300 fourmis part qu' on va là en
faites vous
aujourd'hui on peut éliminer des idées
en fait on peut on peut on peut faire
progresser les sciences naturelles non
seulement par l'observation empirique
mais aussi par un sorte de audit en
complexité voilà si quelqu'un vous dit
que les faux les collines fourmis
fonctionne de cette manière là etc cette
manière là n'est pas tolérante au foot
n'est pas locale et requiert 1500
message transmis entre les fournis par
minute
pas besoin d'aller les riches et pour
conclure que
cette hypothèse-là doit d'être
abandonnée en faveur d'une hypothèse où
fonctionnement de la commune de fourmi
n'est plus dans les rangs faute est
moins complexe j'adore cet argument pour
donner un exemple d'une autre discipline
encore j'ai vu pas mal en économie par
exemple où on se pose qu'est-ce que vous
êtes l'équipe de nash et tout ça et il
ya un peu cette question dont ben c'est
bien beau de prouver qu'il existe un
équilibre de nage mais si maman c'est ça
s'il n'est pas calculable en temps
raisonnable et la plupart des kits de
nash son appel pp a dit est complètement
c'est à dire qu'en gros on pense que
c'est pas quelques longs temps
raisonnable c'est-à-dire qu'on me
l'économie de ne jouera pas cette équipe
de nage puisqu'il faut un temps très
très grand pour y arriver et ça permet
de distinguer du coût des équipes de
nage qui sont favorables
le zap plus facile à calculer qui sont
dans le traité niable facilement souvent
règle histoires de poe excité tout ça
par opposition à des équipes de neige
qui sont imposables en pratique
exactement d'ailleurs parlant d'un
cursus je pense que si on nous enseigne
un peu plus d'informations dans les
cursus de physique alors peut-être que
c'est pas pour toi ta ta ta fait de
l'informatique en fait ben ouais j'ai
fait le tri fait d'accord maroc c'est
pas parce que ce qu'ils font maintenant
je suis à mon époque la catastrophe la
prépa je vais vraiment faire à la maison
mais le programme qui nous a été fournie
était dépourvu d'informatique et la
physique en façade
je pense que c'est au niveau de la
physique qu'il faut traiter problème si
on nous enseigne est un peu plus
d'informatique dans les sciences
naturelles comme sciences fondamentales
sont vraiment les lever haut niveau au
niveau de la physique sciences
fondamentales ccsn les choses sont comme
elles sont aujourd'hui voilà dans les
cursus la première à la science da
sciences naturelles qui jugeait être la
plus importante à donner aux lycéens
c'est la physique
ouais les mots derrière rim est que les
matchs ne sont pas de sciences
naturelles général c'est un outil mais
en fait ce qu eux dans les sciences
naturelles en donne la physique à tout
le monde
puis la biologie c'est au choix en fait
il faut promouvoir l'informatique ou au
stade de la physique
tout le monde doit être sensibilisé à la
complexité algorithmique à la complexité
aux catégories d'informations juste un
peu des bases parce que par exemple
quand l'étudiant fait face au premier
cours d'économie
si la sicile si les sensibiliser à la
complexité première chose qui m'a dire
c'est oui mais ouais les agents sens
rationnel et maximise l'utilité combien
de temps mais en fait des idées comme
bande de lâches melliti de herbert simon
viendront très naturellement en fait
c'est un peu compliqué et non mais je
suis optimiste je pense que c'est que
cette même pas facile ça c'est bien un
concept qui fera moins de résistance je
pense que la théorie de jt telle qu'elle
nous a été enseigné alix moi ou c'est
quoi c'est quoi ce modèle où on se pose
que les agents connaissent les optimaux
et sans ultra rationnelle ça coûte ça
coûte du temps ça ça prend du temps et
ça coûte du temps et du travail après
avant de savoir qu'il occupe et je pense
à demain une des choses qui je n'ai pas
fait de j'ai pas fait d'évaluation
[Musique]
rigoureuse mais je ressens dit que
j'avais des gens de ma promo qui ont été
dégoûtés des cours d'économie alix vous
c'est quoi ce truc où on assume que les
humains sont rationnels de manière le
topic alors est ce que je pense qu'il ya
eu moins de résistance à des aaa au
moins à au moins dire un peu quelqu'un
bientôt un mois mettre un peu de même un
petit bémol en disant ceci est à prendre
avec un grain de sel
vous allez voir après que vous pouvez
bornes et la rationalité des agents et
regarder le temps de calcul qui leur foi
ou le temps de raisonnement qu'il en
faut et le long de ressources et déchets
de connaissances qui leur faut avant de
trouver ses optimaux et en fait pourquoi
ils ne vont pas les trouver et que les
modéliser avec un terreau du site et ça
reste utile quand même ouais ouais mais
c'est pas trop ce cours d'économie de
l'icsc cap et technique
suit ensemble et je n'ai pas aimé non
plus mais c'est pas tellement les
premières critiques que j'aime parce que
il ya d'autres trucs vin par exemple
supposer que les courbes d'offres et de
la demande sont des droites
ça sent le plus choqué encore et je
pense à particulier avec lequel j'ai eu
plus de mal c'est la macroéconomie ou
enfin s'était vraiment passé il n'ya pas
l'axiome n'y a pas de fond enfin ça part
dans tous les sens et c'est un peu ses
traits à dire que j'apporte c'est quand
même un champ pédagogique ou avoir des
lycéens sensibiliser à la complexité
harmonique fera deux meilleurs étudiants
d'université après c'est ce que c'est a
priori tu es vraiment s'est passé je
pense que c'est quand même pas des
notions facilement suffire si tu parles
de bardy derache united on bavarde et
rationalité je fais tu vas expliquer ce
que c'est un bon point de théorie faire
des jeux bac donc lille et parce que
l'idée de bandits de raffinage qui m'a
juste dire que les remerciements c'est
la seule personne à voir un nouvel et un
prix turing
merci mon fils nations et là ils à un
prix nobel d'économie si je me trompe
pas de concept de celui que j'ai en tête
banide rationalité c'est que
l'information qu'on peut traiter et
bornés la quantité d'informations au
sens de shannon mais parler de quantité
d'informations de sanctionner c'est
quand même pas facile
et puis bon il n'ya pas que ça aussi qui
imite ya le temps de calcul
et qui est beaucoup plus dure à
quantifier pour le coup enfin c'est
difficile enfin c'est pas si facile de
mettre une borne sur la quantité
d'informations qu'on va recevoir
c'est un peu plus dur de mettre une
borne sur le nombre de calculs qu'on
s'autorise vous le coût de chaque calcul
mais ça peut être très intéressant et
très pertinent et il va très très bien
mais je suis pas sûr que vous faudra
déjà enseigné la théorie d'information
de schengen pas au préalable et à tori
d'information de shannon répète à
enseigner mais c'est compliqué quand
même c'est quand même pas si simple
peut-être été un peu à l'aise avec les
probabilités benjamin vient bien que je
mettrai plus enfin des trucs de de
calcul habilités sociales et ça pour moi
pas besoin d'aller technique juste 100
civils juste sensibiliser les lycéens au
fait que le savoir ça va pas de soi
parce que je disais tout d'une
information c'est pas l'heure à dos ça
c'est vrai c'est clairement dans
l'économie c'est un vrai problème parce
que les modèles économiques
en fait c'est des contraintes très
difficile à prendre en compte le fait
que l'information est limitée ou
incomplètes
comment la gérer en plus quand
l'information incomplète on sait jamais
trop quoi faire
moi je suis parisien donc mais je mets
des a priori mais bon il ya des gens qui
n'aiment pas ça
la théorie des jeux informations
incomplètes
enfin même l'économie informations
incomplètes façon générale c'est quand
même un domaine ultra compliqué qu'ils
deviennent très vite très technique mais
plus j'adore je déteste dedans mais
c'est quand même pas facile
ben je pense que je pense que tu as
je me suis mal le fait comprendre je
joue je voulais pas dire qu'il faut
enseigner la introduire l'économie aux
étudiants quel que soit le cursus est un
même dans la fac avec des trucs de bar
de charité ou autre mais juste dans
l'introduction de quand on introduit
dans les chapitres introductifs ne pas
choquer l'audience avec eux d utilité
marginale du premier coup et des optimum
qui sortent on sait pas comment et les
agents qui calcule lagrangien de u qui
se dire attention oui en fait
l'information n'est pas gratuite
les agents ne connaissent pas les
optimum des pour l'instant à faire sans
mais voilà c'est un peu comme
l'événement construisit on peut
sensibiliser les gens sur le fait que
ouais c'est un pitre mais l'information
n'est pas gratuite les problèmes n'ont
pas toujours des solutions et on ne peut
pas se donner le droit de dire il existe
un objet mathématique juste parce que ça
nous chante
ouais mais ça n'empêche pas de faire dès
maintenant constructive dans le cursus
par les bus du coût des sensibilisations
qu'autre chose dans l'introduction
sensibiliser les étudiants de fait que
ceci est un mal nécessaire
on va faire la théorie de l'utilité
comme ça en supposant que les agents
sont rationnels juste parce que ça nous
permet de progresser un peu avant
d'aller vers autre chose
en fait c'est introduit de manière très
dogmatique et j'ai vu des cursus à la
fac c'est pareil après aussi une
question de l'âge verrait plus empreinte
de
de former les formateurs là on aborde en
fait le point délicat déclassé en fait
c'est que c'est nous autres prétendument
scientifique c'est quand même grave en
fait envie une époque où nous autres
scientifiques nous pratiquons les
sciences nous publiant des sciences et
pourtant nous ne sommes pas formés nous
ne sont pas sensibilisés suffisamment à
l'épistémologie en fait on est des
praticiens de la science non c'est parce
que c'est que savoir c'est que ça je
vois déjà des gens dire qu'est ce qu'il
raconte suis l'arrêtent
ouais mais en fait j'ai publié pas mal
de papiers scientifiques mais mais en
fait j'ai compris ce j'ai fait mes
premiers pas épistémologique après ouais
après les premiers jours j'ai d'abord eu
des publications scientifiques accepté
d'en dresser super cool mais en fait à
une maturation épistémologique et les
postérieurs y compris en physique en
biologie et se livrer et et cette
maturation épistémologique
pire il me coûte du temps elle me coûte
du temps parce que je suis en train de
me former sur le tas a posteriori ça
fait pas partie de notre cursus est en
fait voilà je disais tout à l'heure il
faut des sciences là je vais vraiment
fâché beaucoup de personnes je vois le
cursus des prêts par par exemple en
france le programme de philosophie
je pense qu'il est très très très
pragmatique de dire qu'il est grand
temps de l'alléger en oeuvre littéraire
et de 10 mètres un peu plus de
philosophie des sciences
par exemple on a une audience qui va qui
va se croire pire c'est qu'à la sortie
des prépas vous avez une population qui
se croient scientifique et l a jamais eu
un court correct de philosophie des
sciences est en fête ou d'histoire des
sciences en fait t'as population qui
sait mais qui sait pas comment on a su 7
c'est suprême et à ce que j'ai dit mais
on le voit par exemple dans les débats
récemment la révolution je vis dans un
pays où il ya pas mal de créationnisme
j'ai grandi dans un pays pas mal de
créationnisme il complète par un
enseignant de sciences parce que tu es
marocain rouge voilà mais je fais ça aux
états unis ou autre et le drame c'est
que la population sans cesse avoir fait
elle va dire oui oui l'évolution c'est
vrai parce que c'est la science mais en
fait elle est dépourvue de d'arsenal
l'historique les ja même pas ne parlons
même pas des pistes est logique
historique pour convaincre
donc je pense qu'il ya une première
étape c'est de sensibiliser l'audience
scientifique à l'histoire des sciences
parce qu'en fait quand on étudie
l'histoire des sciences on devient plus
sensible aux côtés procédure coup tant
itération est en fait en voit ce qu'il a
fallu faire comme conneries pour
conclure que la terre est ronde par
exemple ou que ou que le modèle
géocentrique ne tient pas la route
et quand on fait pas de d'histoire des
sciences
quand on fait de la physique en prépa et
quand on commence comme on commence de
manière un peu brut
le principe fondamental de la dynamique
maudit que la somme d'efforts c'est vers
la masse de ces points d'accès relation
en a tendance à confondre maths et
physique
c'est très grave on a tendance à croire
que voilà il ya des points de départ
enfin il semble comme ça ils sont acquis
et tout le reste n'est que déductif de
la partie de ces points de départ alors
que si on va si on enseigne l'histoire
des sciences
l'étudiant va voir l'induction mais
l'histoire des sciences permet de voir
le côté inductif du savoir la manière
d'enseigner
je parle au moins pour la france et les
pays qui ont des systèmes éducatifs
similaires la manière d'enseigner et
très digne très déductive ouais c'est
très dangereux jeu
réfèrerait des gens qui sortent en prépa
en sachant moins de malades
électromagnétiques et moins de
spécificités des trucs orbitale de je
sais pas quoi des points de lagrange est
un peu plus d'histoire des sciences un
peu plus d'eux comment on a su que ça
comment en séquence est en fait pourquoi
on a déduit que c'est que là le principe
fondamental tient la route
ouais et donc s'il est grand temps de
mettre un peu plus d'induction ok je
disais il est grand temps de mettre un
peu plus d'informer le père en attique
ch de météorites d'information est en
fait il est aussi grand temps de mettre
un peu plus d'un du ctif dans les cursus
ouais mais je pense qu'un premier
première porte d'entrée
c'est une histoire des sciences ça se
rappelle des vidéos que j'ai fait sur le
sol qui accélère vers le haut où j'avais
fait vous tue qu'on m'a pas mal le
mondial ya des gens qui croient pas ça
parce que c'est forcément très très
bizarre mais du coup on a pas mal
demander de le prouver que je peux
partir des loups et des roulades et
d'acquitter générale d'einstein et le
démontrer mais ça va pas vous convaincre
le jusque là cher tu as juste caché la
réponse sous sous la tutelle n'a pas
induit
c'est ça tu n'as pas lundi alors que le
truc vraiment fou c'est le raisonnement
d'einstein qui en 1907 s'est dit atteint
les 6 le sol accéléré vers le haut sa
expliqué qu' après du coup dû inventer
la rectrice général pour que de
naissances à et ses salles à la
réflexion intéressante section 6 et
induction c'est une déduction c'est
intéressant aussi c'est un outil c'est
un outil il faut être fou tu es tout y
est on à déduction c'est ça mais
aujourd'hui je reprends michel serres on
à la déduction dans nos têtes et dans
l'est en fait la déduction en lan
on l'a mécanisée mais la déduction est
beaucoup plus facile à mécaniser que
l'induction
mais autant gagner du temps et
s'outiller plus en induction vu qu' on
peut maintenant sous traiter la
déduction à l'ordinateur
mais la déduction maintenant c'est la
tête de sa venue comme à saint denis
qu'on a rien dans les mains
ouais et puis bien vous pouvez revenir
un peu à michel servent ce que du coup
on s'était arrêté à l'invention de
l'écriture mais
on veut plutôt du support papier pour
pouvoir écrire ou pas que papier papyrus
ou autre est en fait qu il va plus on
continue en fait l'histoire des
civilisations en insistant à cette fois
sur la révolution qui porte sur
l'information sur le traitement le
stockage les missions d'information et
du coup l'étape suivante pour dans son
histoire c'est l'imprimerie bouleversé
accèdent à leur guise sans presque rien
tôt et après une colline après les avoir
collecté est en fait on peut voir
d'ailleurs je peux faire un petit teaser
au livre en le des dans le chapitre iv
du livre on va voir que fait les
échelles de temps peut-être quand on le
vit ce livre si tu vas rachid c'est
comme ça nous met des mois on en train
de travailler sur un livre qui devrait
paraître pour noël prochain et un livre
sur autour d'eux il ya notamment de
rendre les ja bénéfique et des problèmes
de sécurité et tout ça mais avant tout
il fallait faire un détour par la séance
d'information est que ce que savoir
qu'est ce que l'information
qu'est ce que cela représente dans la
grande histoire humaine est en fait si
on voit cette grande histoire humaine on
peut dire est allé il ya eu homo sapiens
maintenant c'est que le plus vieux voilà
la borne en à une borne inférieure de
300 milles avec le récent le récent
fossile de jbd rude donc donc avec ce
récent fossile en sait que c'est un peu
près 300 millions ou homo sapiens donc
on a trois cent mille ans de
paléolithique en fait chasseurs
cueilleurs puis on a dix mille ans de
néolithique
donc tu agriculteurs et puis on a donc
ses agriculteurs là vont inventer
l'écriture on a cinq mille ans
d'écriture et puis depuis l'invention de
l'écriture jusqu'à l'invention de
l'imprimerie on a quelque chose comme
4000 5000 ans et puis depuis
l'imprimerie jusqu'à l'ordinateur on a
quelque chose comme 500 ans ça 400 en 20
ans
et puis depuis l'ordinateur à
l'ordinateur connecté on a quelque chose
comme 50 ans 30 ans quasiment moi c'est
quasiment immédiat c'est ce printemps
une échelle une échelle logarithmique
une échelle logarithmique des temps
est-ce quelque chose dont michel serre
par énormément notamment par exemple si
on regarde le dictionnaire mais ne peut
rien à voir mais juste les plus réveillé
de l'audience normalement aurait dû tilt
et quand j'ai dit transition de
paléolithique et néolithique
normalement on devrait dire mais que
fait la transition paléolithique et
néolithique
dans cette grande image par informatique
de l'histoire paraître qu'est ce que les
yeux qui est ce que l'agriculture c'est
le contrôle de fait pas dans certaines
vallées faire la falaise fallait
chercher la nourriture
c'est un problème de recherche en fait
de ce crunch donc au sens faire un
calcul fait un travail aller chercher
dans la forêt à les piéger un cerf etc
il y avait une procédure pour aller
récupérer la nourriture qu'ils étaient
fastidieuse et quand on avait réussi à
domestiquer en fait le mot est le mot
anglais d'ailleurs très approprié et
henning a dompté le gibier canchas scène
adam l'adopter et les graines qu'on
cueillez on les a domptés et en on a
juste maintenant à savoir qui nous
permet de les reproduire à volonté enfin
à volonté mais a abondé bois et puis pas
juste ça aussi la sélection artificielle
qui fait qu'on choisit certaines femmes
qui marchent bien là là c'est une autre
question mais juste dix ans fait
intéressant parce que juste au niveau
conceptuel quelle est la différence
entre le palais aux tic
le néolithique est la différence entre
des chasseurs cueilleurs et et des
agriculteurs dentaire à gré la
agriculteurs c'est le c-17 différence
informationnel c'est les seconds une
information leur permettant de retrouver
leur nourriture plus rapidement et de
manière plus reprend plus répéter plus
reproductible plus contrôlés sans aller
vers les détails de sélection
artificielle bien sûr c'est nécessaire
c'est une étape nécessaire de sélection
artificielle des graines etc synoptique
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que je voulais te dire que c'est
un détail à mon avis parce que récemment
maintenant on sait que la
sédentarisation de l'humanité qui s'est
fait de manière indépendante dans
plusieurs endroits sur la planète ne
s'est pas faite que par l'agriculture
il ya eu une civilisation je crois dans
la la célestine en bolivie enfin c'est
le premier mot magique at her way donc
je disais pourquoi pourra être pourquoi
je disais que ce qui ce qui est
important dans la transition
paléolithique et néolithique c'est
l'information sur la ressource qu'est la
nourriture c'est parce que maintenant on
a découvert des endroits où la
sédentarisation n'a pas eu lieu parce
qu'on a perdu de l'agriculture il ya eu
d il ya eu déjà eu des sédentarisation
en amérique latine
autour de sites ou les moules étaient
redondantes autour de fruits de mer a
fait d'ailleurs c'est je crois que c'est
les psy chine choraux c'est c'est parmi
les premières civilisations à momifié
l'or noir et il ya un bouquin qui parle
très bien de ça c'est le bouquin à 14
180 terence 491 1 2 ça c'est un bouquin
qui résume un peu les dernières traces
les derniers travaux d'archéologie sur
un an indique latine et cette
civilisation là elle n'a pas débuté en
ayant dompter les grains de blé
elle a juste eu l'information que il est
très efficace de rester au bord de mer
il n'y a plus besoin d'aller faire des
recherches exhaustives
un partout pour avoir de la nouveauté il
suffit de rester là il y à de la
nourriture de manière reproductibles et
fiable dans ce site là et il se sent
sédentarisés non pas autour de grain de
blé qui ont été contrôlés mais autour de
fruits de mer puis après bien sûr ils
ont ils ont ils ont commencé à faire
autre chose ouais et donc ouais donc en
fait même la transition paléolithique et
néolithique on peut la voir avec un
prisme informationnel way est un très
bon voilà donc on a donc je disais 300
millions de pv aux logiques dix mille
ans de néolithique quelques milliers
d'années donner aux logiques avant
l'écriture quelques millénaires
d'écriture quelques quelques quelques
siècles après la prairie et puis et puis
quelques quelques quelques années en
fait après l'ordinateur
ouais émission messi enfin ça c'est très
logarithmique cela je pense que très
difficile d'argumenter contre cette
observation de déchets logarithmique
n'étant ouais mais je pense qu'on peut
passer sur cette île et de
l'accélération
du temps comme ça avec en regardant
juste l'évolution des gènes des des
animaux et des plantes qui nous
entourent parce que c'est français qu'on
a dompté celle dont on est ce que bon
les gens ont tendance à penser que par
exemple ogm c'est un truc récent mais
sauf qu'en fait la modification
génétique des des agricultures et des
animaux domestiques quelque chose qui
conseille à très très longtemps et qui a
bouleversé la manière dont on survit en
outre on vit que et ça c'est vraiment
une s'entourer utiliser l'information
enfin grosse collecter l'information
génétique animale ou végétale qui me
convient et les progrès qui ont encore
plus en ce sens et ça s'accélère patate
ça arrive et il n'y a pas si longtemps
on aura bouleversé pas mal de choses qui
se font ça c'est bien discuter du moins
naturelle naturelle naturelle parlant de
naturel et de l'hydrogène
la magistrate à la pomme de terre va
vaches et un marocain de familles
marocaines et dealer que le thé n'est
pas une tradition banques mais en fait
tu le mets marocains par exemple crois
que le tc à truc c'est un truc
traditionnelles ancestrales depuis je
sais plus combien d'années je dis ça
peut se faire à peine de deux siècles au
maximum trois siècles que les premières
consommations sont rapportés et en fait
ça fait que depuis très récemment que le
thé sucré est devenu une chose
et parce que le sucre c'était un produit
de luxe
jusqu'aux années 50 du 20e siècle ouais
ses rivaux d'un siècle du coup que les
gens les gens ont tendance à oublier à
quel point les choses sont récentes et
des foires en tendance à sacraliser des
choses comme étant des traditions ou
comme étant des des choses naturelles ou
des choses ancestrales
donc ces séances et radan que c'est bien
il ya beaucoup de débats en fait inutile
aujourd'hui autour de mots comme naturel
traditionnel
mais ces gens là c'est le col à saissac
tradition c'est traditionnel et culturel
et non il ya un autre mot qui j'aime
bien un autre mot qui me gêne c'est bien
parce que je n'aime pas authentique
l'authenticité
ça fait partie de notre authenticité il
est entendu que si ces authentiques
c'est bien voilà c'est comme ça que les
ans c'est comme ça que c'est comme ça
cause ça est refusé ben en fait il ya
bien sûr il ya des arguments en faveur
de ça mais bien sûr si plusieurs
générations faisait ça c'est qu'ils
avaient une bonne raison de le faire
voilà mais il faut arrêter de sortir ça
comme argument c'est c'est une bonne une
ristic
c'est une bonne logistique pour juger
que si quelque chose est bonne si
quelque chose a été faite pendant
plusieurs générations de la même manière
et sait c'est qu'il ya de bonnes raisons
de l'adopter mais faut pas que ça soit
faut pas que ce soit un argument par
exemple le sucre est subventionné le
maroc un pays où l'état subventionne le
sucre mais en fait ici l'état arrête de
subventionner le sucre c'est la guerre
civile
juste les deux ans le gouvernement avait
commencé à lever certaines subventions
et puis les gens râlaient parce que
c'est des produits de consommation
nécessaire avec maintenant il est
entendu que le sucre est nécessaire tant
que marocain consomme trop de sucre cis
est le département d'économie du amati
fait il ya il publie des graphiques par
pays je crois que le rcd graphique d'un
port d'importation et d'exportation et
je crois que le maroc c'est le seul pays
où ils te représente un pays par un
carré et puis très vite fait de plus des
petits carrés donc le ca est le gros
caresse à être pétrole à petit et en
fait il est carré la taille des
carrières représente la l'infraction des
importations en cette matière le maroc
est le seul pays
j'ai fait des eaux plus sûres pays ou
moins de la région
le seul pays nord africains ou européens
ou le careï du sucre est suffisamment
gros pour apparaître et tu débat même en
famille avec les amis ou de chichi en
fait faudrait fait le thé sans sucre
depuis que j'ai quitté le maroc je bois
du thé sans sucre et les gens en fait
pour eux et ouais c'est c'est plus
authentique qui s'est passé
au fait si on voit l'histoire de la
consommation du thé au maroc la majorité
de cette histoire elle était en sucre et
les gens aujourd'hui il fait il ya un
gros billet dont je parlais du sucre et
du thé au maroc mais on peut généraliser
sa à plusieurs autres problématiques où
les gens ont tendance à oublier à quel
point d habitude sans récente
ouais on retrouve ça dans la
nationaliste dans tous les dix noms dont
beaucoup beaucoup de situations où il
est entendu que ceci est une tradition
et que c'est bien que du coup il faut
pas aller à l'encontre des questions
appelait les traditions que l'on a
il ay ay ay ay et des biais
psychologiques un peu gaza donc par
exemple le biais de familiarité qui fait
que ce qui nous est familier vient plus
facilement l'esprit commandement de
d'efforts cognitifs et du coup on a
tendance à apprécier sa et à aimer ce
qui nous est familier du coup si un truc
qu on a vécu tout le temps avec on a des
gars on a l'impression de dire on entend
ça sur généralisée à dire que du coup ça
toujours été là ouais et en plus on a
tendance à avoir une valeur affective
par rapport à ça qui biaise un peu
ensuite le raisonnement qu'ont web après
on voulait vraiment pas parler des gens
là désolé pour ceux qui ne se sentent
pas concernés par les débats sur le thé
et le sucre mais en fait ce que je
voulais évoquer ses notes de naturel
dans des questions comme la recherche
alimentaire alimentaire
sans beaucoup de blocages de sites est
le livre tout à l'heure 414 en 1495 en
fait le bouquin en 1491 raconte une
partie de l'archéologie qui a permet de
retracer la découverte du maïs en
amérique latine il ya une interview
d'une prof à berkeley qui disait donc
l'auteur je pense là maintenant les
théories qu'on a sur la découverte de
maïs convergent toutes vers des explique
vers des procédés expérimentaux tels que
si je les faisais aujourd'hui dans
l'amont laboratoire j'aurais greenpeace
à ma porte
la prof c'est en fait une sorte de taxe
d'arc da de palais au palais aux
botanistes
cette fois c'est par taleo botaniste
mais pas laisser des gens qui
s'intéressent à l'histoire de enfin ils
essayent de retracer en fait comment des
espèces qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
l'agriculture ont pu être créés à partir
d'espèces sauvages et il ya beaucoup
c'est très passionnant aujourd'hui toute
cette recherche autour de comment les
légendes amérique latine ont découvert
le maïs
en fait tu l'as dit la fête le maïs qui
si ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
blé ce que ce que nous dans l'ancien
monde on a découvert le blé l'orge
c'est des graines d'après ma
compréhension de ce qui est rapporté
dans ce livre de ce que disent ces
biologistes c'est que la transition
entre les ancêtres du blé de l'orge et
le blé et l'orge
c'est pas si violent que ça mais la
transition entre les candidats ancêtre
de maïs et malisse est vraiment assez
surprenante et il est très probable que
ce qui a été fait ce qui a été entrepris
comme comme procédé itératif insistant
sur quelques générations
c'est qu'il ya probablement eu une
conscience à un moment donné j'ai des
civilisations d'amérique latine qu'il
faut commencer à 'stress test' est en
fête des plantes série physique au jeu
je vais je vais déformé les propos des
spécialistes donc je réfère au livre ça
sans un excellent livre la date servait
de cadre à 1491 c'est un an avant
l'arrivée de christophe colomb vers une
des premières des premières une des
premières idées reçues que que je
corrige ce livre c'est la catastrophe
démographique de l'amérique latine et de
demain des amériques en général surtout
des catastrophes en fait dit me l'a dit
voilà des catastrophes épidémies et
pandémies pandémie et il commence le
livre commence par l'erreur a fait une
erreur historique
la marche d'un archéologue d'un autre
pilote allemand
c'est un anthropologue allemand qui est
allé étudier en fait une tribu au 19e
siècle et il commencé à dresser des
conclusions en conclusion sauf que
c'était un des pionniers et ses
conclusions en fait office de textes
vocation est en fait l'analogie que dawn
hauteur c'est un peu que si vous
récupérez les surveille les survivants
désolé 2 de la référence historique mais
si vous récupérez les sites survivants
des camps de concentration nazis
et imaginez que vous récupérez ces
survivants là qu'ils n'ont pas été
imaginé que ces survivants imaginons une
fin de deuxième guerre où les survivants
des camps de concentration ont été
isolés dans une forêt et on continue à
vivre et en fait c'est sûr vivement la
représente une très petite fraction de
la population initiale donc tous les
savoir faire ont été perdus tous les
métiers l'artisanat etc sont perdus du
coup ils vont probablement retrouver un
mode de vie un peu bruyant primitif et
est donc ce cet anthropologue est venu
19e siècle dresser des conclusions sans
savoir que ce qu'il était en train de
regarder
c'est une petite poche de quelques
centaines de survivants d'une
catastrophe qui a dessiné des dizaines
de milliers d'habitants dans la région
en question dans la forêt en question
donc en fait c'est un instrument qui ne
représente pas du tout la civilisation
dont ils sont issus et donc il va
dresser un tableau très primitive etc
etc le début du malentendu autour de
l'amérique latine où est au tour d
amérique en général c'est un ce
malentendu est dû au fait que les
anthropologues les pionniers de
l'anthropologie nous ont oubliés on
n'était pas conscient du fait que
attention je suis face à une petite
poche de survivants qui ne représente en
rien ce que ce qu'étaient les gens avant
ici et y dresser des conclusions et c
est donc il corrige cette heure-là puis
il part ça ça parle de beaucoup
d'aspects en fait de l'ancien monde de
comment ils ont d inventer 0 au fait ya
une idée il ya eu une invention
indépendante du zéro des maths et a eu
beaucoup d'inventions et la modification
à la momification elles étaient
antérieurs d'ailleurs aux égyptiens là
bas et dans la partie i was kim ce qui
m'a interpellé
donc les deux choses le fait que en fait
on sait qu'il ya eu des sédentarisation
indépendante de l'agriculture
descendante organisation autour des
fruits de mer mais aussi deux parties
sur le maïs j'ai jamais j'ai jamais fait
gaffe jamais fait attention au fait que
en on ne connaît toujours pas on n'a
toujours pas avec certitude au moins
jusqu'à l'écriture de ce livre
l'ancêtre du maïs alors que le blé on a
beaucoup parlé avant qu'on a beaucoup de
candidats l'orge et à ce qu'on appelle
que je connais pas de maire en france
est improbable il ya iliad il ya des
céréales sauvage et ans et avec très
forte croyez que c'est les ancêtres
c'est à partir de ça qu'on a pu recréer
le blé etc
et en fait ça permet de relativiser la
notion de naturel qu'est ce que le maïs
est naturelle le maïs n'a jamais existé
ça fait
qu'est ce qu'être naturel en fait les
gens ne formalise pas ce mot mais ma
tentative de comprendre ce que la
majorité de la société attribue à smos
est obtenu par des procédés indépendant
de l'intervention de l'homme d'un accord
et dès que ces obtenu par des procédés
ou l'homme va activement accélérer la
recherche en fête ou accélérer la
sélection c'est de faire une sélection
biaisé par son intérêt devra juger du
coup à la pomme de terre c'est pas
naturel c'est pas naturel le blé c'est
pas naturel
les moutons et les chèvres compte pas
aujourd'hui le chihuahua c'est pas trop
naturelle chihuahua c'est un loup qui se
portent très très mal je pense pas que
le chihuahua auraient survécu important
que nous dans la nature et donc en fait
c'est là où la grille de lecture
algorithmique et nécessaire est donc il
faut accepter que l'humain peut à deux
guides et la sélection naturelle
accélérer l'obtention de certaines
propriétés bien entendu il y aurait il y
aurait des effets secondaires qu'il faut
étudier et c est qu il faut prendre le
temps de juger avant de conclure mais il
ne faut pas dogmatiquement interdire par
exemple la recherche sur les ogm
sous prétexte que c'est pas naturel ben
pourquoi alors vous enlevez vos dents de
sagesse
je dirais genre gens aux gens qui
voudraient par exemple interdire la
recherche sur les ogm les dents de
sagesse
c'est naturel pourtant c'est un défaut
ou un défaut de fabrication parce que
les mutations qui en a qui on arrive
qu'ils ont alloué notre budget osseux à
la boîte crânienne se sont produites
plus vite que les mutations nécessaires
pour ne plus produire trop de trop de
molaires
parce que maintenant on a une mâchoire
plus petit que que de l'époque b de nos
ancêtres qu'il y avait des mâchoires
plus grande et donc un budget osseuse
dans la tête c'est la voilà on y est le
raisonnement de complexité il ya un
budget un budget en budget en hausse le
budget au ce il ya un temps de canton de
fabrication ou un temps de recherche de
solutions et la solution plus gros crâne
a précédé la solution plus de dents de
sagesse parce que ça fait des gangrènes
dans la mâchoire ou sa fédé tekkari où
je sais pas quel type de de dérangement
ça peut faire et pourtant les gens ne
sont pas choqués aujourd'hui par par
l'ablation des seins des gens vont très
joyeusement enlever leur danse jazz sa
sagesse du coup tout est en train de
dire que le théorie de l'évolution en
fait c'est si vous vous la reformuler en
termes modernes
ça revient quasiment à dire que
l'univers est un processus algorithmique
quelque chose comme ça qu'on s'est juste
non non il est pas il est pas un
processus algorithmique mais il s'est
très vite voilà je prêche a convaincu
c'est très utile aujourd'hui l'une des
meilleures manières de lire l'histoire
de la grande histoire de la vie est
alors inc et voilà ça processus de
recherche donc les scilly tegmark
raconte bien ça dans son livre life clip
audio
les vitraux de 1 010 et raguse avec marc
si on peut on peut si on veut se
restreindre à très peu de loi on peut se
restreindre aux lois de la
thermodynamique mais laissée libre
tout système physique augmente
l'entropie en fait la vie est un
processus qui augmente l'entropie de
manière plus rapide que la l'envi du
coup il est avantagé par le second
principe de la thermodynamique
il ya même des papiers avec des travaux
rsa en fait dans ce sens l'injustice
parce que c'est un peu contre intuitif
pour ceux qui connaissent rapidement la
seconde loi détermine et nick ont classé
on l'adapté en vie dynamique a dit que
tout dans tout système clos d'entropie
augmente et du coup ça c'est bizarre
parce que l'impression que la vie a
tendance à structurer un peu les choses
a dit me un entrepôt pour elle même en
fait c'est en fait elle minimise le
désordre peau elle même qu'est ce que je
fais en fait qu'est-ce que je passe mon
temps à faire la journée je prends de
l'énergie dans un environnement jeu
l'utilisent pour ranger ma chambre est
rangé mon ordinateur et me portait bien
et elle avait mes vêtements mais chemin
faisant je rejette de l'eau sale de la
machine à laver et des déchets etc
si on considère le vivant dans son
environnement
c'est en se lavant et bien le vivant
c'est une découverte de la matière c'est
une découverte permettant à la matière
de beauté encore plus d'aller encore
plus vite vers la dissipation et qui
pour le coup si on veut boucler avec les
notions de l'information entrepris et
extrêmement reliés à la notion
d'information notamment parce que en
gros si une mesure du désordre du coup
nous sont un type et un au sud de la
relation du canal de son information
mais si elle survient parce qu'en fait
je pense qu'on a on bombe était pas mal
d'audience avec les histoires de
physique fondamentale et d'épistémologie
mais si on va être vraiment très
terre-à-terre aujourd'hui dans des
débats de société
lachance qui a pas mal de sophismes dans
les débats sociétés ou des empêcheurs de
tout d'aider des blocages psychologiques
dus à ces biais là que c'est naturel
donc c'est bien ou c'est naturel donc on
ne peut pas le reproduire
on va parler c'était probablement d'un
qu'est ce que l'intelligence qu'est ce
qui est artificiel dans l'intelligence
et serra et beaucoup de gens dans ce
type de discussion refuse l'idée qu' il
va être possible de reproduire de
manière artificielle l'intelligence bas
avant même avant d'aller à
l'intelligence parlant même parlant
d'abord juste du vivant il faut accepter
que l'évolution c'est pas trés optimale
la preuve on a des dents de sagesse on a
un coccyx dans les orteils mal barré qui
se tordent des fois avec la luz valgus
syndrome la boule faire l'orteil du pied
on a plein de défauts dus au fait qu' on
est le résultat d'une recherche un peu
en roue libre qui n'a pas été très guidé
par aujourd'hui on a la possibilité de
la guider dans des sens qui nous seront
favorables donc si on veut être vraiment
égoïste en tant qu'espèce vivante
il est grand temps de jeu plus grandir
en tant que société dans nos débats et
d'arrêter débloqua d'arrêter de bloquer
ou d'arrêter de sortir des arguments qui
on va parler de qui le recul tu veux
parler d'intelligence artificielle
ouais donc avant il faut le voir parler
du fait que j'ai mis j'ai mis sept ans
avant d'enlever mes dents de sagesse
parce qu'avant je pensais que si je suis
j'ai une dent de sagesse que ce que
voilà ce que c'est qu'il est sage a
laissé pousser branchement dentiste
m'avait dit en 2009
wave autant de sagesse vos dents de
sagesse de risque de pousser
horizontalement mais il risque de ne pas
pousser horizontalement qu'on peut soit
attendre et voir
soit les enlever de manière préventive
ça aurait été très facile comme
opération à l'époque avec cette phase
avec ce sophisme du naturisme dudus si
c'est naturel c'est mieux j'ai laissé
pousser ma dent de sagesse résultat est
là un peu défense et la mâchoire et il a
fallu une opération très douloureuse
pour l'enlever donc pas quoi par exemple
très concret de bêtises de bêtise et de
perte de temps et de temps et de
ressources et est en fait ce cette
anecdote là on peut la généraliser sur
la société
aujourd'hui heureusement aujourd'hui on
a des antibiotiques
j'ai pu me faire arracher la dent de
sagesse un coupé un peu dos de la
mâchoire et prendre des antibiotiques
avant j'aurais une gangrène dans la
match où je ferais je ne serai plus là
pour raconter l'histoire
en fait la société humaine devrait
commencer à raisonner de cette manière
si on veut se maintenir comme espèce
faudrait grandir
sur pas mal de débats sociétaux et une
fraction de ces débats là sans retard
des parts par des défunts l'acide et des
sophismes des sophismes comme celui du
sophisme du naturel ça me permet citer
encore une fois michel serres qui disait
que kiki qui parle souvent de lui xiv
roi tout puissant de france qui je suis
qu'est ce qu'il avait en gros il
souffrait à la bombe sous 3 ouais j'ai
pas j'ai pas vu mais ça va en parler
mais je sais que la d re france à la
goutte maladie de riches mec a quand
même souffert d'une grosse partie de sa
vie comme un malade alors qu'il était
l'homme le plus puissant au monde
alors qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens
qui vit se porte très bien jusqu'à des
âges très avancé que sans grande
souffrance
michel serres par sourds de un mec qui a
65 ans qui va voir le médecin pour la
première fois enfin tu vas voir un
médecin parce qu'il a mal à sa première
vraie douleur qui l'a parce que bas
pendant toute sa vie banalise
antibiotiques on a tout ce qu'il faut
pour premier sentier des oeufs
parce qu'en fait il à bouquin qui
s'appelle là c'était mieux avant on
entend souvent cette phrase c'était
mieux avant c'était mieux avant et 10 et
ben ça tombe bien parce que moi avant j
étais je peux en parler
ce cas est réparti à l'elysée avant ça
pue et et il racontait comment c'était
choquant ça en fait c'était pas
concevable de laver ses sous-vêtements
de change et des sous-vêtements une fois
par jour mais il ya des choses qu'on
prend pour alan de soi mais juste iatria
plus moi j'en attends tu m'attends à une
polio par des années 50
parce que le 6 le vaccin de la polio
n'était pas systématique et les
handicapés la vie et c'est des choses
que notre génération croit comme allant
de soi en fait ça va de soi que en fait
quatre enfants il ya quatre enfants qui
survivent non ça va pas de soi jusqu'à
la génération de mes grands-parents ou
celle d'avant pas voilà fallait faire
fallait faire 12 grossesse pour finir
avec cet enfant ou six enfants ou si on
est chanceux
on fait cette grossesse et puis il ya
deux enfants qui survivent et la femme
succombe à la 8ème grossesse c'est trash
mais mais c'était pas c'était pas rares
et on a tendance à oublier que sur
certains une métrique ça va très très
bien aujourd'hui mais c'est pas pour
autant que tout est bon à prendre dans
le progrès technologique bien sûr on
n'est pas là en train de dire qu'il faut
s'allier il faut tout automatiser tour
en d'artificiers le prendre que
deuxièmement il ne faut juste pas fermer
certaines portes juste parce qu'elles
sont artificielles juste parce que les
ogm sans sens artificiellement obtenus
sont obtenus par un calcul fait par
l'homme et non pas par un calcul fait
par la nature qu'il faut les bannir
faudrait faire des recherches et tout
comme nos ancêtres enfin des recherches
jusqu'à obtenir le maïs et la pomme de
terre faudrait faire des recherches
jusqu'à obtenir des solutions à des
problèmes alimentaires aujourd'hui très
sérieux qui vont s'aggraver avec le
réchauffement climatique et
l'augmentation de la population humaine
il faut plus cacher vous faut plus y
mettre
faut pas croire naïvement qu'un retour
idyllique à la nature afin de sauver pas
du tout absolument pas du tout notre
notre notre notre délivrance
il faut accepter que notre délivrance
sera technologique ou n'aura pas lieu
notre délivrance de quoi de du fait que
nos autres civilisations humaines
plus le temps avance plus il est
probable qu'en disparaissent c'est juste
ça a été comme ça pendant depuis
l'apparition de la vie la règle c'est
l'extinction et ya aucune raison pour
qu'on soit une exception aucune raison
il ya aucune raison pour que l'ex
l'espèce humaine soit une exception à
cette règle
il suffit d'un météorite similaire à
celui des dinosaures ça y est à plus de
l'espèce humaine est donc la seule la
seule issue quand bien même je pourrais
accepter que pour les débats alimentaire
peut être que
le retour à des modes de production
locaux etc va résoudre certains
problèmes je suis d'accord je peux
discuter ça mais face à une météorite
c'est pas le yoga naturalisme qui va
nous sauver et moi je suis désolé mais
je ne veux pas que parce que il y en a
qui vont te dire bah si c'est un
météorite
si ces voix-là cesser nos destinées je
suis contre je pense que je nous sommes
les dignes représentants d'une espèce
formidablement intelligente
formidablement ingénieuse et nous devons
refuser ce fatalisme et nous devons
adopter la technologie comme étant en
fait la seule issue qui nous est offerte
de manière à maîtrisable puisque c'est
la seule issue sur laquelle on peut non
même agir il ya tout le reste tout le
reste c'est la der du destin sur lequel
on peut pas agir est donc en fait en
tant que société il faudrait faudrait
aller plus vite
faudrait aller encore plus vite sur
beaucoup de francs en fait et donc aux
tons autant le monde va bien aujourd'hui
ça les gens se portent de la misère
diminue les l'attraction de populations
humaines sous diminue mais les
inégalités augmentent et mais surtout en
fait plus grave encore le coup le coût
pour faire sauter tout ça diminue aussi
à au moyen âge au moyen-âge les gens
mouraient par manque d'antibiotiques
mais il n'y avait pas une arme nucléaire
permettant à quelques individus de
décimer des centaines de millions
d'humains aujourd'hui
en fait le coup en fait on a à la fois
une amélioration de la qualité de la vie
mais à la fois une sorte de pas
démocratisation parce que ses parents le
terme sorte de ça devient à la porte et
sorte de crédit à une diminution du coût
diminution du coût de nuisance et il
devient de plus en plus accessible à une
minorité du même un minorité humaine mal
malveillante de nuire à une majorité du
vin aujourd'hui il suffit il suffit
d'une minorité bien motivés donc pour
pour minorités bien motivés dans un pays
peut fabriquer une bombe
bien sûr ce n'est pas aussi facile que
ça mais ça devient de plus en plus
faisable
voilà c'est celle à la bombe nucléaire
est là et il n'y a pas que la
montgolfière il ya beaucoup de de risque
existentiel auquel il faudrait faire
surface
donc il ya catastrophe nucléaire il ya
des catastrophes biologique
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure aux ogm mais
pour viol alors plus on fait de la
recherche en biotechnologie puis il est
probable que une linéarité malveillantes
découvre des outils puissants de luise
ans et aux bien sûr et les risques
naturels les théories et etc et une face
à tous ces risques là il serait
hypocrite de dire que on a une autre
solution que la technologie
ouais du coup qu'il est le plus gros
risque
ça vient transition aucune des
dimensions l'arrivée mais je pense que
le plus gros risque sur lequel on peut
agir c'est le refus sociétal d'accepter
que l'issue était je pense que le risque
c'est celle au pc l'opinion humaine
c'est en fait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui est très difficile même dans
des démocraties où les gens sont très
éduqués aux sciences de défendre juste
aller la recherche sur les objets me
répéter ou la recherche sur
l'intelligence artificielle
aujourd'hui c'est devenu une sorte de
gros mots pour être respectable il faut
prêcher les vertus de l'humain
voilà le risque le risque est que
l'humanité n'a donc pas de manière
accélérée est suffisamment rapide le
développement technologique comme
condition tu penses que c'est ça le plus
gros risque c'est que les gens n'adopte
pas assez vite n'accepte pas assez vite
les technologies et on va dire à
plusieurs risques qui peuvent tomber
sous suis là je t'invite indigne de gens
qu'elle quels sont les autres risques
ben moi j'avais parlé un peu de cantons
et bien choisir ton sujet de thèse par
exemple bon monsieur je sais que vous
savez pas d'ailleurs c'est un sujet de
thèse c'est d'abord notre c'était
d'abord la tolérance aux fautes dans les
systèmes biologiques sais c'est que
chemin faisant que je me suis rendu
compte que ce type de raisonnement peut
porter sur les zone euro puis sur / en
fait sur l'or leurs déclinaisons
artificielle et donc sur la manière de
faire douter commencé ta thèse en
voulant faire de la biologie
théoriquement sujet 13 un sujet tel
initialement ouais je voulais comprendre
pourquoi pourquoi la biologie et
tolérante au foot tu peux expliquer un
peu ce qu'est tous les ronds se foutent
la tolérance aux fautes dans un système
c'est l'aptitude à continuer de
fonctionner malgré la défaite la
défaillance d'un sous-ensemble
significatif par exemple depuis le début
de cet épisode on a dû perdre quelque
chose comme plusieurs millions de
cellules bondées toi il attend en
fonction en apparence normalement tout
comme au début de l'épisode on a un peu
plus fatigué je pense mais il n'est pas
très évident qu'on a perdu des cellules
en observateurs externes une colonie de
faire mieux j'ai mentionné tout à
l'heure les collines chauffour millions
je peux aller écraser quelques fourmis
ou plusieurs fourmis les fourmis vance
se réadapter à louer les tâches etc à
reprendre les tâches de celles qui sont
mortes et serra il continue de survivre
chaque jour en perd à peu près je crois
qu'à son euro
et pourtant le cerveau fonctionne plutôt
bien et les systèmes qui ne sont pas
tolérants faute c'est le système qui
contiennent ce qu'on appelle en anglais
les singles point ils surveillent les
points uniques des pharmacies un terme
en français c'est c'est les points
critiques par exemple un système
centralisé et reposant sous une
monarchie
par exemple dans les systèmes de
gouvernance d'une monarchie ou
présidence à la française très simple cd
système très centralisé et donc il
suffit que le président ou plus roi
vaval pour que le système marival et
donc c'est un système qu'il présente un
single pointant fail donc ils présentent
un poids un point de faiblesse
aussi si le dirigeant est tout puissant
voilà ses dirigeants et tout puissant
par exemple un système dirigé par un
dirigeant puissant n'est pas un système
robuste
lorsqu il suffirait d'attaquer le
dirigeant est ce qui est pour prier de
type d attaque soit en dessous le cul je
suis je sais pas une invitation à
effectuer sur si le président
s'effectuer du coup c'est une façon de
les pieds notation encore plus
problématique qui est de de soudoyer de
web par exemple donc en fait donc un
système dirigé par un dirigeant unique
c'est pas très fiable parce qu'il
suffirait pour une puissance étrangère
de courant pour ce dirigeant alors qu'un
système où le pouvoir est très distribué
très décentralisé l'exemple de la suisse
par exemple où les communes ont pas mal
de prérogatives puis après il est
content qu'ils emmènent leur
constitution prend trailer loi prendre
puis après à la fédération qui n'a pas
beaucoup de droit de regard sur
certaines choses locaux et l'a
d'ailleurs les suisses connaissent très
rarement leur président parce qu'en fait
il ya pas de ya pas de personne qui
incarne le pouvoir et il est très facile
je connais des suisses qui ne
connaissent pas le président du moment
mais qui connaissent le président de la
république française ou le
roi d'espagne parce que voilà ces
personnes ification des pouvoirs ou même
le premier ministre d'espagne aller
n'est pas le roi ouais alors qu'en
suisse en fait le pouvoir est tellement
décentralisée qu'on ne connaît pas en
fait l'incarnation du pouvoir grâce à
tour chaque année et et quand s'est
décentralisé en général c'est plus
robuste est ce que je voulais que ça
soit bien des centres et bien voilà
parce que voilà c'est des fois c'est 200
trains si c'est mal de centraliser ça
peut être pire que sa qualité j'espère
que pire que quand c'est centralisé il
ya des vertus à la centralisation a bien
sûr et il ya toujours des compromis mais
il faut un peu de centralisation et
décentralisation et donc l'algorithmique
distribuer cette discipline qu'il ya pas
mal mathématisée ce phénomène de la
tolérance aux fautes ses propriétés ou
seulement que le manque de ses
propriétés et ça m'a plu enfin le
physicien en mois a été bien servi par
pas ma part cette question est en fait
le premier problème auquel j'ai bossé
sur quel beau c c étant donnée un réseau
de neurones par exemple pour un modèle
très mathématisée simplifiée d'un réseau
de neurones qui perd une partie
deux cents 200 dessine héros de ces
neurones ou de ses synapses
quelle est l'erreur quand c'est quand
est ce qu'on peut dire des choses
intéressantes sur cette erreur est ce
qu'on peut la borne est elle à un
contrôle et c'est donc mon premier
papier se tait des petites preuves sur
comment de majorer l'erreur résultante
d'une défaillance d'un groupe de
neurones dans un réseau de neurones et
en fait avec un peu de chance et de et
de temps en fait j'ai découvert que
c'est un problème qui peut être
intéressant si dans le cadre des réseaux
métaboliques et j'ai collaboré avec des
gens de l'université john hopkins de
l'hôpital universitaire john hopkins sur
une déclinaison du même problème dans
l'ensemble de métabolites
c'était protéines des bouddhas rnd
bouddha tdd dire des molécules des
molécules qui constitue son métabolisme
sans organiser un peu comme un système
distribué ou l'un est un catalyseur de
l'autre qui rentre dans les réactions
chimiques et produit l'autre et cetera
jusqu'à ce que après plusieurs réactions
chimiques les a suffisamment de
d'hémoglobine pour transporter l'oxygène
dansant et en fait on peut se poser la
question quels sont les noeuds quel sens
les métabolites critiques tels que si on
les enlève les n'a plus de techno
globine où le taux d'hémoglobine de les
descend sous un seuil critique
l'étal mortels et ses noeuds là vont
être un peu comme les rois ou les
présidents de tous les exemples
politique
les biologistes antennes internes pour
ça ils appellent ça les gènes essentiels
et en fait on a regardé un peu juste si
on peut dire des choses intéressantes
sur ces gènes essentiels si on peut pas
prédire un peu leur nombre faire des
pour l'instant c'est très très
approximatif c'est c'est le propre des
heures des sciences biologie c'est 0-0
qui disait il disait il semble paradoxal
que les sciences les sciences exactes
commence là que l'acte initial chez plus
de la citation exacte de au sol mais il
pointait le fait que le point de départ
d'une science exacte c'est de maîtriser
l'approximation
donc ouais ouais il disait que ça sente
paradoxal mais en gros la science exacte
ne consiste qu'en une maîtrise de
l'approximation
en fait on est au stade très
préliminaire où on a pour l'instant des
estimateurs très primitif
d'une part ils ont de nombreux moyens de
gêner essentielle et mais le
raisonnement il est très à gauche il y
les traits agronomiques
inspiré de ce fait il ya un mot clé que
je voulais il est mentionné au début du
podcast et c'est l'indépendance
vis-à-vis du substrat ce qui est élégant
en fait dans la théorie d'information
c'est qu'on peut commencer à étudier des
propriétés indépendamment des systèmes
qui les portent donc l'information la
lettre aux états est un être qui
existent indépendamment de fait qu'il
ait écrit sur une feuille ou qu'il ait
prononcé par une corde vocale ou qu'il
ait tapé sur un ordinateur est en fait
dans la théorie d'information on a
commencé à formaliser cette histoire de
date d'indépendance vis-à-vis du
substrat est en fait la tolérance aux
fautes d'un système elle ne dépend pas
vraiment de la matière qui constitue un
système ne dépendra de l'agencement
battue comme la lettre o la lettre e ils
ne dépendent pas de lancre que tu va
utiliser et ne dépend pas de la matière
qui constitue à cordes vocales ou est ce
que elle est prononcée par ta cordes
vocales en chair humaine ou par le haut
parleur d'un ordinateur avec des
matières plastiques
en fait la lettre aux dépens juste de
commencer cette matière va bouger
d'appareils la tolérance aux fautes d'un
système est une propriété qui ne
dépendra pas forcément pas vraiment de
ce que le système est fait de chair et
d'os ou de fourmies ou de neurones ou de
métabolites mais de l'agencement des
constituants de ce système
donc c'est une propriété indépendante de
substrat est ce que j'aime beaucoup en
fait pour comme physicien fait dans
l'informatique c'est l'indépendance
vis-à-vis du substrat mai et pour
revenir tout à l'heure aux débats
sémantiques et aux blocages des débats
sociétaux sur l'intelligence
artificielle
je pense qu'une partie du malentendu
vient du fait que les gens ne sont pas
suffisamment sensibilisés au fait que
l'information la mémoire l'apprentissage
sont des notions indépendante du
substrat gré fait là
la propriété à prendre est une propriété
qui ne dépend pas du tout du substrat
qui va l'emporter ou la propriété
mémorisées elle ne dépend pas on peut
mémoriser sur sur un papier écrire lundi
est longue est né en 1801 1987 on
l'écrit avec de l'encré bleue sur du
papier blanc s'il va pas changer si on
l'écrit sur os microsoft word sur un
flash disk et ça ne va pas changer non
plus si on l'écrit sur un disque dur un
roux tu sais pas quel autre système
l'information et les abats indépendant
de tout cela et on a du mal dans
beaucoup de discussions dont j'ai vu
beaucoup de j'ai entendu beaucoup de
podcasts des démissions pellet en etc
et souvent il ya une traction
significative du temps qui est perdu
juste parce que une partie des
débatteurs ou où les deux enfants
informations apprentissage mémoire et
substrats qu'il porte et ça c'est la
porte ouverte aux ceci ne peut pas être
fait de manière artificielle parce que
en fait on va confondre les capacités
humaines à la matière qui constitue
l'humain c'est pas parce que l'humain
fait de la mémorisation avec du carbone
et d'hydrogène qu'on ne peut faire de la
mémorisation qu'avec liquide relais mais
c'est pas parce que l'humain joue aux
échecs en mobilisant des
neurotransmetteurs sur des synapses et
des neurones configuré de telle manière
qu'on ne pourrait jouer aux échecs que
en mobilisant des neurotransmetteurs et
en fait souvent je pense qu'une partie
des malentendus sur l'intelligence
artificielle est due à la confusion
substrat les propriétés informationnel
la propriétaire informationnelle et
souvent en fait c'est le propre même
s'esquisse
je pense qu'on peut même arguer que
argumenté que c'est la définition même
de l'information
c'est ce qui peut décrire en fait un
agencement ou insultant
une matière ça fait c'est ce que c'est
les propriétés qui sont indépendantes du
constituant c'est vraiment
l'ordonnancement l'agencement le pattern
le motif mais si c'est sa principale
raison enfin c'est clairement une des
raisons j'ai dit qu'une grande partie
est perdue dans une grande partie du
temps de débat est souvent perdus a
argumenté que en fait il est comme si
les postulats l'intelligence ne peut
être que naturel voilà c'est un postulat
parce que voilà ça a besoin d'eux a
besoin de chair et d'os et de sang et de
sentiment et je pense qu'il ya un effet
il ya un des trucs à qui correspond à ce
que tu dis c'est que beaucoup de débats
vont dire que une machine ne peut faire
qu'un calcul ou que c'est comme ça du
coup ils vont imaginer que le cerveau ne
fait pas de calculs ou vous faire
quelque chose qui n'est pas qu'ils ne
correspondent pas du calcul ça c'est sûr
c'est un truc qui très récurrent et du
coup bon là ça revient après ce qu'ont à
dire c'est juste l'importance de
l'information même pour la physique même
pour l'information est quelque chose de
très très fondamentale et voit le
cerveau fait du traitement
d'informations et ce qui est plus
important en fait si on réfléchit aussi
à ce qui se passe 20 dans une société
aujourd'hui les jobs les mieux payés en
fait le gros du job de n'importe quel
job bien payé s'est souvent vu tu
récupères et d'information anaïs cette
information même traiter cette
information et émettre des informations
donc je sais vraiment l'information
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui vers nos
économies pour exactement
et d'ailleurs ça serait pas mal quand il
est grand temps qu'on définisse que ce
qu'on entend par intelligence tu penses
que c'est un terme sur lequel on est pas
mal d'accord en fait ça a vraiment
l'aptitude à résoudre un problème et je
pense que même quand bien même ça tu
allais pas je pense qu'il est très utile
dans les discussions sur sur ce type de
sujet de se mettre d'accord en fait on
fait une convention sémantique pour
juste par se perdre en fait dans je
crois que c'est mis d'accord sur autre
chose pour le livre acheté quiz sera la
télé c'était pour lire ou relire on va
dire traitement automatisé
mais en fait là je disais juste
intelligence
qu'est ce que l'intelligence qu'est ce
qui en fait pourquoi on dit que kasparov
et intelligent dans les échecs
parce qu'il sait résoudre le problème
battre l'adversaire avec ses gratte et
même juste parce que lorsqu'on parle de
problème les gens ne savent pas trop ce
que c'est un problème un cadran juste
objectif objectif traitement de
l'information
ce que fait kasparov s'il regarde il est
une donnée qui est le l'équipe l'état du
lieu
et puis traite cette donnée et puis
après ils ont rien une décision quand tu
traites on doit y sont en fait c'est ce
qu'il va faire
en fait ce qu'il a comme ce qu'il a
comme tâche en a en fait venir et
kasparov en lui donnant une tâche quand
même ouais dit voilà il a une objection
ce qu'il est important de parler
d'objectif ben oui alors lui oui mais
parce que c'était klaus a fait un
objectif
qu'est ce qu'on entend par tâche puisque
pour beaucoup de gens vont dire vision
pas un pré fléchir comme tâche je suis
pas nettoyé je pense enfin nettoyer la
salle de bains et là ils vont dire bon
algorithme peut pas faire ça mais si on
se restreint juste à l'ensemble des
instructions avant traiter de
l'information puisque un robot qui veut
nettoyer fait c'est très laid cette
information et je pense vraiment juste
s'intéresser juste la notion de traiter
l'information ça swing vraiment là où il
est vraiment la difficulté est là où en
fait ya vraiment un gain énorme à faire
en termes de capacité de traitement de
l'information via via des algorithmes
des machines ou via le cerveau humain
donc si je reviens vers ta définition
que ta définition de l'intelligence est
capable de traiter l'information
bonne très bon très bien oui d'une cache
défini objectif est de me faire une
information d'un potager c'est vrai
mettons nous d'accord alors sur
atteindre un objectif entreprenant
atteindre un objectif en traitant
l'information nécessaire ouais il est
quand même il ya un objectif parce que
on peut il peut traiter l'information de
telle sorte à perdre il ya d'ailleurs
des programmes
je viens d'apprendre ça c'est qu'il ya
des compétitions de programmes d'échecs
où l'objectif du programme est de perdre
en fait il ya des gens qui se mettent en
couple et donc je conçois un programme
déchets que tu consens un programme
d'échec si tu gagnes et tu as peut être
au dessus
est-ce que c'est difficile de perdre
très divisée est ce que c'est si dur que
gagnerait en fait c'est les canadiens où
ils ont été bloqués un objectif donc en
fait je pense que si on veut minimiser
le nombre de de deux notions à mobiliser
pour définir intelligence la notion la
plus inévitable ses objectifs
parce qu'en fait ça va rejoindre le fait
de terminer qu'en fait ce qu'il a
terminée kasparov
il a terminé quand le roi de
l'adversaire est mort ouais donc
astaracais de champion du monde d'échecs
des échecs qui avait perdu face à un
truc qui me fait il ya un argument de
terminaison comme estime moi en fait
esti mois avec tel crédence que vous que
veut dire cette photo il ya une sorte de
terminer à une sorte de terminaison est
un critère de terminaison un objectif
battre l'adversaire parce que si tu mets
pas l'adjectif si tu mets pas deux
objectifs tu laisse la porte ouverte à
l'âne en terminaison traiter parce que
plus à sahorre peut passer son temps à
traiter l'information et la partie peut
continuer indéfiniment en fait si tu
donnes l'objectif de je peux donner à
magas part of l'objectif faire en sorte
que l'adversaire ne gagne jamais ça peut
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que c'est pour
ça que c'est pas mal de revenir les
échecs et une grande histoire entre les
échecs et l'intelligence artificielle
parce que la garaiya dans une récente
tribune dans itunes gaspard aux 10es les
échecs c'est la drosophile i c'est la
drosophile de l'intelligence mais c'est
comme drosophile ya c'est la mouche
super étudié par les biologistes un peu
les échecs c'est un peu notre ceux qui
essaient de conceptualiser ce que c'est
que l'intelligence pour nous l'un des
échecs st c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
comme terrain de jeu basique et
d'ailleurs été propriétés
comment ça pas tout les projets en
éducation qui bien sûr mais si c'est un
bon légaux c'est un bon terrain de jeu
primitif et en fait on peut il ya deux
compétitions d'échec ou le but et de
perdre et donc on met deux 2 jours des
chèques
informatique automatique l'un contre
l'autre et le but c'est à chaque fois je
déplace les pions de telle sorte à ce
que tu ne perds pas parce que ce soit
moi qui perdent on peut imaginer en fait
un jeu d'échecs où l'objectif est de
maintenir le jeu le plus long post
longtemps possible avec les experts sont
difficiles mais on peut imaginer des
dames il ya des versions de dames et des
jeux de dames
on peut ajouter des options de
récupération de pions et on peut
concevoir des programmes dont l'objectif
est de ne jamais terminé le jeu donc je
joue en fait toi tu joues pour gagner ou
pour perdre jura tu joues pour gagner
par exemple et moi je peux jouer contre
toi
de telle sorte à ce que le jeu ne se
termine jamais encore fait je pense
qu'il est très nécessaire de parler
d'objectif et donc en fait si on se met
d'accord en fait je disais dans les
débats sémantiques
le plus important c'est pas la
définition en fait le plus d'avancé que
les gens qui discutent soient d'accord
sur une définition
donc mettons nous d'accord intelligence
ses capacités à atteindre un objectif
comment ce que tu viens d'écrire en
traitant l'information
ok donc je traite l'information est ce
que tu dis décrivait tout à l'heure les
jobs les mieux payés c'est très peu
d'information conclut ressortir une
information traiter l'information
conclut ressentir une information de
telle sorte à ce que après un certain
moment on a atteint l'objectif augmenter
le chiffre d'affaires battre
l'adversaire et c'est donc la notion
d'objectif et trail arrive très
naturellement en fait dans le dans la
dans la conceptualisation de ce que ces
qu'intelligence et il y aura on va voir
qui aura des notions en fait
instrumental perception mais il faut
d'abord pour atteindre cet objectif
pouvoir évaluer la situation
donc faut percevoir la situation alors
l'adversaire a encore de pian une reine
et cetera donc je perçois première
partie du traitement
je traite jeu donc je regarde ce que ce
que je viens de percevoir me dit de mon
objectif il a encore sans roi et j'ai
une série
et de méthodes de ristic grisou qui me
permettent de jouer le prochain et des
camps se définit l'intelligence comme la
capacité à atteindre un objectif l on
voit que c'est une définition très
inclusif très très très inclusive les
abeilles sont intelligentes les fourmis
santé jantes les humains sont
intelligents mais en fait il suffit à
chaque fois de définir pour quels
objectifs donc et les humains sont plus
est et c'est là où on va fermer la porte
au relativisme et on va voir que les
intelligences ne se valent pas parce
qu'on peut définir des problèmes dans
lesquels les abeilles ne pourront pas
d'attribuer un nom qu'on peut définir
des objectifs
n'en déplaise aux relativise n'en
déplaise à certains il faut pouvoir
classer les concepts il faut pouvoir
dire ça inférieurs à 1 ferreira paix il
faut pouvoir mettre au moins des ordres
partiel sur certaines directions bas
dans la dans le jeu d'échecs l'humain
est plus intelligent clavé c'est un fait
donc si vous dites à un humain battez
tel autre humain aux échecs il a plus de
chances d'y arriver qu'une abeille parce
que son système de perception lui permet
de comprendre ce que c'est qu'un jeu
d'échecs etc
et puis sont certaines de cons
commission lui permet de déduire quelles
sont les mouvements nécessaires à faire
et donc de la notion je disais et les
inclusive et donc elle englobe elle
englobe non seulement les êtres vivants
mais elle englobe les les abstractions
des ensembles d'être ayant par exemple
les sociétés les villes mais les
entreprises non tandis que coca cola et
rusé mais coca cola n'est pas il n'y a
pas de substrat qui porte feuille de
coca cola on a un coca cola est
indépendante de substrats qu'il
appartenait coca cola existe comme
entreprises et les portées par
l'ensemble des employés qu'il avait dans
les années 50 elle est encore porté par
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des employés qui
qui la constituent probablement beaucoup
moins beaucoup plus je ne sais pas mais
aussi par toutes les machines qui
fabrique coca cola et par tout les tous
les tous les endroits où est ce taux
sans stocker les formules chimiques de
coca cola par son management qui va
décider de comment placer les publicités
etc etc on tandis que coca cola et rusé
c'est à dire que l'objet l'abstraction
coca cola arrive à bien générer du
profit à se maintenir en vie et avoir
son objectif qui est que les gens bois
et boivent cette voie sans et et est en
fait il n'y a rien dans cette définition
qui ferme la porte à une automatisation
à sa mécanisation
il suffit de connaître l'objectif fait
il suffit de connaître l'objectif et il
suffit de se rendre compte que la
manière de résoudre cet objectif
elle est indépendante du sud on a des
preuves en fait on a des preuves de
concept aujourd'hui on sait que c'est
qu'un avion peut voler parce qu'on a vu
des oiseaux voler mais après on a
fabriqué des avions indépendamment du
substrat qui nous a servi de preuve de
concept on n'a pas à fabriquer des
oiseaux on a pas on n'a pas fabriqué des
on n'a pas dupliquer les oiseaux de
manière mécanique on a compris qu'il ya
une histoire de portance de dld et tout
le reste c'est du métal et des hélices
qui n'existe d'ailleurs pas dans la
nature ce que la nature avait d'autres
contraintes la nature avec des
contraintes d'irrigation sanguine etc
qui ne lui permettait pas d'avoir là où
par exemple peut pas avoir que tout ce
qui tourne comme cela dans la nature
parce qu'il faut continuer d'irriguer
[Musique]
tout comme on a compris que la capacité
à voler elle résulte des propriétés de
l'arrangement de la matière de l'oiseau
et non pas en fait de la matinée en fait
elles résultent de l'arrangement de la
matière qui constitue l'oise où elle ne
résulte pas de la matière même qui
constitue l'eau c'est pareil
la capacité à jouer aux échecs et ne
résulte pas de la matière qui constitue
le cerveau kasparov une résulte de
l'arrangement de la matière qui
constitue le cerveau de kasparov et on
peut même se battre le pack kasparov aux
échecs avec
arrangements et et je ne sais pas
pourquoi en fait il ya encore beaucoup
de gens très intelligents qui refuse
qu'ils refusent l'idée que
l'intelligence c'est quelque chose de
très belles très mécanique
si on prend ta définition qu'armand les
ordinateurs sont d'aujourd'hui sont
largement plus intelligents que nous
pour énormément de tâches que vérifier
par exemple la validité d'une preuve
formelle en mathématiques celles écrites
en langage formel sacrément marchand est
ce que pour un ordinateur c'est beaucoup
plus facile qu'elle pourra nuire mais
payet gérer les emails création spam
recommander des vidéos youtube faire du
sous titrage automatique des vidéos
youtube c'est celle il ya deux tubes et
même bien plus forte que des armes et du
vent mais ouais c'est juste que voilà on
a encore pas encore fait c'est tout cas
on a pu fabriquer des calculatrices
avant de fabriquer mais je crois que les
femmes les calculatrices ont précédé les
aspirateurs
j'invite les gens à chercher ce qu après
il vieille tradition de notre machine à
laver c'est la vaisselle enfin si
travail sincère elle ne sait plus
récente la calculatrice
j'aimerais que ce qu'il entend
exactement par calculatrice mais de
calculatrices électronique de base
ok bah je sais pas trop ce que je pense
que c'est vrai mais aussi après le
transistor j'imagine peu après dans une
autre une autre invention récente
allez la brosse à dents vieux donc je
suis ma brosse à dents électrique à la
brosse à dents électrique avance à dents
électrique ou en restant sur le lave
vaisselle des chances la vaisselle ses
parts à la pl pascaline et l'a précédée
de la vaisselle noël servi pourtant la
pascaline et la rode résolu un problème
intellectuellement plus difficile que
laver la vaisselle
enfin sous un aspect dans un sens qui
sait c'est pour ça que la théorie de la
complexité faut se mettre d'accord sur
qu'est ce qu'on entend par par difficile
le temps là si on définit par déficit
pour l'homme le temps que ça prend à
l'homme de laver un verre de laver la
vaisselle et le temps que ça prend pour
l'homme a multiplié
imaginez que pascal aurait pu très bien
qu'un tour pascaline faisait unification
ne met pas ce qui n'est pas juste des
additions à les additionner les
additions même les additions ça peut
être fastidieux
imaginons une pascaline très large on
aurait pu la fin il n'y avait rien il y
avait aucun aucune barrière
technologique pour passer de la
pascaline suis pas trois chiffres ou
quatre chiffres à la pascaline à 1
minute chiffre à mes chiffres d'accord
et pourtant et l'a précédé la pascaline
a précédé a précédé la vaisselle et
pourtant elle a autorisé une tâche à
l'interdiction en fait c'est pas parce
qu'une tâche est intellectuelle qu'elle
et qui n'est pas mécanique
en fait j'ai peut-être d'une bêtise tout
à l'heure quand j'ai dit c'est plus
difficile que faire que laver la
vaisselle en fait non en fait c'est si
on calcule le nombre d'opérations
élémentaire qu'il faut percevoir le vert
le prendre de tournai m le chiffon etc
il ya beaucoup de calculs en fait d'un
banc dans la manière humaine de laver la
vaisselle pour le coup parce qu'ils sont
et beaucoup fécule non puisque beaucoup
de calculs complexes en fait c'est plus
difficile par danser plus dissuasive de
la vienne avait celle que de calcul que
de que de faire des multiplications et
pourtant on a tendance à avoir les maths
le calcul commun une tâche
intellectuelle donc difficile et la
laver la vaisselle comme une tâche
répétitive d'encre acide ballon en fait
là talal laver la vaisselle c'est une
tâche qui pas par la parole
si on regarde le nombre de calculs qu'il
faut faire très difficile et j'ai
entendu dire faudra vérifier mais il est
entendu dire que la pascaline qu'on a
été inventée donc au 16e qui 7e siècle
xviie siècle a été considérée comme un
frein et des gens parler vraiment
d'occasions comme d'intelligence
artificielle et jean rejeté
d'intelligence de la pascaline et enfin
il est tout ce débat sur l est du coup
est-ce que c'était une invention du
diable ou est-ce que ça allait remplacer
l'humain et tout ça qui n'est pas très
différent du débat d'aujourd'hui je
m'assure par la passe quand même mais
j'ai une autre analogie
jusqu'à très récemment en afrique du
nord au moins probablement partout dans
le monde on pouvait se faire passer pour
un magicien juste si on arrivait à
prédire les astres des équipes les
éclipses irait prédire les clips ce ca à
relever de la magie
si tu prédit une éclipse veux tu t'étais
savent et était ta carrière de prophète
était garantie et pourtant maintenant
c'est que c'est une tâche purement
mécanique et automatisable basse et ses
symboles de l'histoire l'histoire de
traitement d'information h à chaque fois
que quelque chose passe du mystique du
mystérieux à l'automatisation mécanique
on se rend plus que très content que ses
magasins quartier qui disait ça oh non
c'est pas danser l'autre smic mais carte
étudiant c'était ce qui est décédé deux
ans mais qui un minsky qui disait que
dès que dès qu un jury mccarthy mccarthy
bassamat quartier et qui donne dès qu'un
problème est résolu on appelle puis ça
de liège rive droite se bat aujourd'hui
ouais en fait aujourd'hui on a tendance
à voir les fêtes s'est pas encore très
performant ça fait plein de bêtises
ça ne fait toujours pas le ménage
unia mais c'est pas pour autant ce
n'était pas un argument pour dire
qu'elle ne dépassera pas les facultés
rien n'est fait et que des commandes et
qu'on revient aux fables le fait que
l'intelligence humaine le résul de rien
d'autre qu'une série de réactions
chimiques casse tout cas casse tout de
suite y habitent
mais il n'y a aucune raison pour que ce
soit pas reproductible très après
expliquant on ne sait pas ouais
au final si on regarde si on regarde pas
les gentils que ça a été mais on regarde
ce que les experts qui étaient sondés
même je pensais pas mal de chercheurs on
n'y a finalement je pense la haine très
grande majorité pense qu'on finira par
avoir des algorithmes même ce qu'on cite
comme étant des sceptiques ton rallye à
forte la mienne le cas il disait
récemment fait le débat la question de
la question de l'intelligence
d'atteindre d'intelligence humaine
atteindre pas l'intelligence humaine et
plus d'une question ce qui est une
question c'est juste combien de temps il
nous reste et la partie est du bas salat
le débat ne porte pas sa encore des fois
je vois des gens cités des experts il
voit les experts disent que et on n'aura
jamais d'intelligence ni volume alors si
on regarde les trois quarts centre y
turing le quart des new in town in town
ces propos sont très très clairement son
centre est univoque et univoque
c'est pas une question pour lui en fait
il n'y a rien de magique pour lui d'
aucune raison pour qu'on ne puisse pas
atteindre l'intelligence humaine
question de temps benji au pareil
récemment conférence de la conférence
sur la sécurité de l'iaa à puerto rico
il a bien sûr et là il a passé plus de
temps à évoquer les faiblesses de daisy
actuelle mais c'est bien il ya rien dans
les lois de la physique qui empêche
l'arrivée d'une forte donc lui voilà
donc pareil pour lui c'est une question
de temps et le dernier donc le plus sexy
que detroit donc le plus dans le déni
parmi les trois c'est celui qui le plus
dans le déni face à hadji à deux niveaux
humain et aux questions de sécurité des
risques existants c'est vraiment pas de
tous les trois c'est le plus dans des
salles hui il tient des propos ou pour
lui par exemple les gens qui
s'inquiètent des risques existentielle
de l'arrivée de liesse se sont peu ou
comme zhou ji c'est comme ça
s'inquiétait de la surpopulation de mars
mais juste parce qu'il ya un programme
se passer là qui vont explorer mars donc
le troisième donc même le troisième est
celui qui est le plus dans le
eni on va dire il dit que c'est qu'une
question de temps et en fait pas besoin
d'être de se référer à ces experts rien
rien dans ce qu'on trouve qu'on vient de
décrire depuis le début de ce podcast
il ya rien dans les lois de la physique
homme qui en cache
salut ni à deux niveaux humain de viol
ne viole aucune loi de la physique c'est
pas mes heures perdues perpétuer mais
après la question du coup c'est plus
quand est ce qu'on faisait arrêter
faisait la même chose faisable oui
comment quand est-ce que c'est là où il
ya des bas mais c'est là où il ya des
bras mais mais en attendant en attendant
faudrait faudrait pas faudrait pas se
louper
il faudrait pas se louper parce que
parce que depuis une autre question qui
se pose par rapport à l'intelligence
artificielle au niveau humain c'est
lorsqu'elle apparaît est ce que ce sera
à quel point ce souverain est-ce qu'on
est ce que ce sera trop tard corbeau est
ce que est ce qu'on est ce que ce sera
catastrophique si évidente et jean
sarsiat les niveaux non ça dépend
comment la conçoit vous n'êtes pas je
pense que pas besoin même d'aller vers
lille il ya deux niveaux humain pour
parler des problèmes en fait donc on a
défini l'intelligence ici comme la
capacité à atteindre un objectif est en
fait donc on va définir l'intelligence
artificielle dans le reste de cet
épisode comme tout comme dans le livre
comme la manière automatisée d'atteindre
un objectif est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
ce qu'on appelle les ja et 3d ziana
rocky alésia faible c'est des procédures
mécanique répétitives qui ont des
objectifs très restreint n'est donc que
la cie fier des photos sous titré des
vidéos et sur des objectifs très
restreint aujourd'hui le fait de le
faire de manière automatisée et très
rapide pose déjà problème parce que si
cet objectif est mal animal aligné avec
des contraintes de sécurité
on peut vite aller vers
le désastre par exemple si cette ia et
là là je vraiment là on parle padilla
surhumaine des j en parle peu ce que je
vais dire là s'applique à la régression
linéaire agression le truc le plus
basique
le truc le plus le truc le plus idiot du
traitement automatisé de l'information
aujourd'hui si on lui donne comme
objectif maximiser le temps de résidence
dans un réseau social
ça c'est une question je pense que tout
le monde est sensibilisé à ça mais si
cette procédure mécanique découvre un
jeu de paramètres qui fait que les gens
restent plus longtemps sur les réseaux
sociaux
elle va faire jouer ce jeu de paramètres
si ce jeu de paramètres implique de
recommander plus de vidéo haineuse plus
de fausses informations plus d'appels
heures de retard tapez le combat et
d'appel à l'affrontement social pas elle
va faire plus de complotisme et là pas
besoin de nommer une plateforme versus
l'autre parce que c'est un problème en
fait indépendant de ses envies tire même
de la volonté des plateformes
c'est un problème ses conséquences de la
définition de l'intelligence et le
chemin de l'objectif pendant voilà de
l'objectif tu me demandes de maximiser
le temps de résidence sur ton site
je te trouve une manière tu me tues m'a
dit de maximiser tu m'a pas dit maximise
le temps de résidence sur 20 sites mais
ne me polaris pas la société où on
recommande par exemple des vidéos
complotistes et là on le voit récemment
avec des plateformes qui commence à
prendre conscience du problème
il est par exemple youtube a annoncé
publiquement agir pour ne plus
recommander des vidéos complotistes des
recommandations médicales
des recommandations médicales à côté
d'autant que les folies médicaux adresse
fait que mettent les recommandations
médicales un peu sorti de nulle part où
on va dire à des malades de cancer en
phase terminale fait du yoga et buvait
de l'eau et de la méditation de pleine
conscience
vous allez guérir et youtube maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est explicitement activé
par exemple toutes les autres
plateformes aussi prennent conscience du
problème que il ne suffit pas juste de
donner un objectif à unias aussi bête
qu'elle soit et pour croire que le
problème est réglé en fait il faut
commencer à mettre des contraintes
explicite ne pas vérifier que le contenu
est pas complotistes n'est pas n'est pas
franchement ça c'est sur le sujet de des
sujets des conseils médicaux
il ya un poète du poète je crois qu'il
était probablement il était catholique
je pense qu'il n'était pas protestants
un poète catholique du xviie siècle
c'était le goûter merckx étaient 17e ou
le 16e l'invention de l'imprimerie
septfonds 15e enfin 15e et c'était
nicolas je crois boileau je crois
nicolas boileau qui disait en fait à 7
ce qui s'est passé avec guttenberg c'est
que la la il était devenu en fait part
dans un parc steinbach lutter déjà de
lutter en fait jusqu'à avait fait lutter
c'est traduire martin luther il avait
traduit la bible en allemand et puis
avec guttenberg
les gens commencent à avoir des bibles
commencé à lire la bible dans leurs
grandes man natale il n'avait plus
besoin de cet intermédiaire qui était
l'église pour qu'elle leur dise quels
sont les préceptes religieux et je crois
que c'est nicolas boileau oui c'est lui
et ouais donc je disais un nicolas
boileau il disait dans un poème tout
protestants tout protestants une bible à
la main étaient 1 tapez était devenu un
gros tout protestants maintenant se
permet de dire que ce qui marche et ce
qui ne marche pas dans la langue rockets
ce qui est bien avec fait en gros avant
on avait l'autorité c'était le c'était
là le vatican pendant l'église est
aujourd'hui à cause de ces saloperies
d'imprimerie guten berre et de martin
luther qui a traduit la bible dans les
dents dans les patois locaux tout
protestants commencent à oser se
prononcer
il se désole il se désole de la
multiplication des sectes il disait tout
protestants une bible à la main étaient
devenus pas je crois tout comme ça et
pour lui voilà c'est un peu comme le
médecin aujourd'hui qui va se désole de
l'existence de doctissimo et et des
conseils médicaux sur youtube
maintenant à toute personne munie d'un
moteur de recherche était devenu médecin
et s'auto diagnostiquer un cancer
et maintenant on a des ia qui traite de
manière automatisée les requêtes sur
internet des gens et si elle voit que
quand tu dit aux gens qu'ils en cancer
il est triste c'est ce que ça va faire
ou si vous vous dites aux gens que dans
une vidéo que ceci est une cure miracle
et après vous voulez vous les entretenez
dans des recommandations de vidéos
killers qui continue à leur dire des
choses comme ça et que si on remarque
que ça attire l'attention plus que des
vidéos en use de d'experts de l'inserm
de l'institut pasteur benglia qui les
passionne fait on n'a pas besoin d'être
consciente surhumaine intelligente
en fait elle va juste voir les chiffres
parlent ainsi le contenu
les hôtes eric attire plus que le
contenu ennuyeux des experts
liam a recommandé le contenu et les
hôtes eric et les gens vont commencer à
faire du yoga quand ils sont enfin ce
thème du concert et c'est très grave ou
ne pas vacciner leurs enfants et on a
des épidémies et ça c'est encore plus
grave et les chiffres mais peut-être que
je pense qu'il n'y a pas trop de gens
qui font du yoga en phase terminale de
cancer ils vont plutôt faire des
chignons et des radios graduée aux
thérapies j'espère mais par contre le
problème de des vaccins c'est un
problème suffisamment grave pour que l'
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
l'inclût cette année en 2019 elle a
inclus et parmi les 10 premiers dix plus
grandes menaces dans la santé publique
vacciner ainsi donc la réticence à
vacciner on a aujourd'hui des poches
juste à côté de chez nous en suisse là
et une poche répit dé nick qui s'est
prononcé je crois à morges est et d
écriture ferney séoul et c'est pas drôle
sparrow de vivre sans 2009
et là on a un problème de sécurité désir
qui est très terre à terre en fait on
parle pas de skynet 2 2 et 2 euros les
deux je sais pas quoi qu'elles font
saisie de science fiction etc je pense
que une des choses qui nous font mal
donc moi je disais donc une partie de ma
tête c'était la robuste et tolérance aux
fautes dans les systèmes biologiques
donc l'autre partie celle que tu sais
que tu connaissais en fait c'est celle
que tu croyais être con sujet principal
qui a fini par devenir jetons suivi
principaux acquis avant les fêtes ici
dit kenzo tiers les deux tiers de plus
de les trois quarts de mes papiers c'est
parce que lui vivant sur sa sur la
tolérance aux fautes désire donc en fait
donc maintenant 3 deux tiers aux trois
quarts de mes recherches pour tu verras
tolérance aux fautes dans les ja et
cette question là il n'a pas besoin
dia surhumaine ou d'y afficher risques
pour exposer le disais tout à l'heure et
gaston minières non le fait d'avoir des
données empoisonné on avait traité ça
allait parler ça dans un épisode dans
son rôle
s'il ya des mauvaises données dans un
vent un jeu d'apprentissage
ils vont fossé il vend fossé
il vous faut c'est l'objectif même en
fait modifier l'objectif des 10 ans ils
sont lavés les îles saint yzan le label
parce que si l'objectif c'est connaître
le label bas comme eux ils viennent avec
des faux labels il faut ce même
l'objectif
ouais et la tolérance aux fautes des ia
est un sujet très terre-à-terre en fait
n'est pas fils chéri style n'est pas
s'est passé pas de l'ordre de la
science-fiction et malheureusement même
des collègues dans le milieu académique
avait tendance est maintenant c'est plus
le cas jusqu'à 2015 16 c'était très
risqué de dire qu'on travaille sur la
sécurité désir lanterne de carrière par
l'extérieur trop seul je suis j'ai eu la
chance de la fête à la conférence
histoire sociale pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est l'un des plus
promis n'en peut être même le plus
promis non des chercheurs ont ni à ceux
qui qui a le vin qui mieux le plus en
avant le problème de sécurité en iroise
sécurité au sens textbook auteur de
textes book avec peter bambic le
directeur de recherche et professeur à
berkeley et donc se voir en salle des
professeurs à google à nos professeurs
dont il est professeur à berkeley
il est l'auteur du texte évoque le plus
le plus cité en fait
l'universitaire le plus cité devient
donc c'est pas pas un expert ce pas un
expert de plateaux pelés et il me
racontait que lui quand on candidate est
il caché même sécurité dizaine on n'aime
pas et même pas l'intelligence
artificielle en fait ce qu'il était venu
en plein hiver à ce qu'on appelle
l'hiver de l'ia ouais mais c'est 90 dans
les années 80 avec elle cherchait donc
qui se considère candidat terre des
postes de profs ils disaient qu'ils
allaient publier disait qu'il n'est pas
là pour travailler sur la recherche
opérationnelle il a le travail et ça en
plein de terme en fait et qui vend
théorie des jeux c'est plutôt
idéologique inductive soumise à sion ces
visages
même le père m'a intelligence
artificielle c'était tabou et dans quoi
parce qu'en fait je discutais du fait
que la défricher en fait le terrain
génération en fait aujourd'hui on peut
dire sans trop se cacher quand on fait
de la recherche sur l'intelligence et
grande partie grâce aux huiles
essentielles belle monde c'est grâce à
lui gilliane le requin et tous les
autres qui ont peu suivi après france et
non en fait on descend dans les périodes
en fait qui sur l'ia et c'est ici à
huawei en chef sioui ils ont suivi ils
s'étaient plus dans la capacité dans la
les performances de dia lui il a vu très
tôt en fait malgré la résistance de
l'establishment de l'époque que ça va
poser des risques conséquents et qu'il
faut se les poser en amont et pas en
aval qu'il faut se poser avant avant
d'avoir et dans quoi on évoquer la
question de la question de la carrière
scientifique la carrière académique du
point dubié de respectabilité que pour
être respectable à son époque pour être
acceptable il fallait ne pas dire qu'en
faisait de l'intelligence artificielle
non même pas donc là en fait en terme de
2 en termes d'obstacles la génération de
russell bengio de cas et je payais
tonnes ils ont fait face a vraiment des
obstacles beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
grand aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est à la mode par contre
la sécurité de l'intelligence
artificielle et à ses outils sas est
resté tabou on va dire jusqu'à 2015 16
c'est jusqu'à 2015 16 cpc peut-être pas
fallu valais peuvent aller ou valait
mieux pas travailler sur
des aspects techniques de la sécurité de
l'eia par sa carrière mais c'était
évident qu'aussi qu à l époque 2015 et
sera si l'origine ouais mais oui dans
quoi il ya une poignée de d'autodidacte
un peu hors du circuit classique et puis
mais il y avait aussi dans dans le
circuit classique y avait quand même
il y avait des gens à versailles avait
avec se disait fait jusqu'à 2015 valait
mieux pas pour sa carrière de dire que
mon plan de carrière c'est travailler
sur la sécurité désir est depuis en fait
depuis les premiers donc fait depuis on
a eu en fait les frais les deux
adversaires et aline pause on commence à
voir que bah en fait c'est très facile
en fait de tromper la zone euro n'y a eu
les papiers libellé venant des paravents
même y avait 2,2 dès 2004 sur la sbm a
commencé à voir des choses qui tournait
pas rond
rey et le pôle de ningde poisoning et
l'évasion samson et rendez compte dès
2015 2008 y avait des papiers de 2004
2008 sur ai vu je n'ai point à nîmes
puis après il ya le papier ouailles de
le trio y avait d'un des auteurs et des
coups de fil aux dents sur seraient des
jeunes puis avait des papiers sur
l'empoisonnement et puis ce sont les
vasières et sas surtout donc poussé
ambiance était spectaculaire en fait
envoyé qu'un réseau de neurones qu'on
disait être surhumain sur la
classification en images il suffisait de
lui injecter un petit bruit pour que il
commence à dire qu'un panda est une arme
à feu teletubbies est hélas il y avait
commencé à voir une prise de conscience
sur sur les aspects techniques de
sécurité qu'en fait j'ai en fait ouais
en fait les legends fait c'est pas c'est
pas une histoire de skynet ou de futurs
c'est juste c'est très très
terre-à-terre en fait comme problème en
fait évader à un système de dca cette
action dans un aéroport
et puis récemment avec les affaires 10
secondes les scandales
les scandales des réseaux sociaux des
manipulations de masse sur la je pense
qu'on a maintenant encore plus
d'arguments en faveur d'al et les
manipulations de masse et de
l'empoisonnement en fait on a vu les les
enquêtes en tout cas c'est ce que les
enquêtes empoisonnement dans le sens
manipulation par une minorité mais c'est
ce que en tout cas les conclusions de
l'enquêté du sénat américain s'était pas
c'était pas c'était pas l'oeuvre
c'était pas l'oeuvre de plusieurs
millions de quand c'était des petites
poignées de main une petite minorité
était capable de créer du contenu et
d'empoisonner des systèmes de
recommandations pour que une opinion
publique se dirige vers à 100 sous un
autre et là on a déjà des problèmes
terre-à-terre on parle pas de papa de
via qui va tuer les humains ont les
remplacer on parle de dia qui va
convaincre un maximum de gens de ne pas
vacciner leurs enfants
j'en vois que ceux qui ont un savoir
plus vers les vidéos de ce portail vidéo
qui ont pas quelques-unes de mes vidéos
ci qui on parle un petit peu n'est pas
un peu mou et là sur le livre de
podcasts les impôts cas ce que j'ai fait
avec là et avec eux
chris brown cas sur le future of life in
situ et puis aussi quelques-uns des
résultats fait aussi aperto rico moi je
mettrai tous les liens en commentaire là
je vais bientôt devoir y aller on va
falloir conclure doucement je pense que
je pense que ce que fera et revenir sur
le podcast pour parler plus longuement
de la série en fait moi je pense que si
on veut résumer il n'y a vraiment rien
de déjà il n'y a pas besoin de se poser
des questions compliquées pour voir que
l'intelligence est un acte mécanique
automatisable 2 2 il n'y a pas besoin de
supposer l'arrivée d'une ia consciente
ou super humaines etc pour se poser des
questions de sécurité très grave il
suffit d'un bon algorithme de
recommandations pour faire basculer
l'opinion publique vers je sais pas
déclencher une guerre civile c'est très
grave
et là pas besoin de pas besoin de vos
boutures manipulation d'opinion publique
pas à petite échelle il ya eu les
lynchages ce qu'on appelle les lynchages
en inde ya eu des lynchages provoquées
par des brumes un générés par des images
je retouche et diffuser de manière
virale sur what that way et là on abuse
45 moi je crois juste comme ça juste sur
un malentendu de photomontages 45 mois
faire basculer une élection sur un pays
de 170 millions d'habitants
c'est quand même quelque chose il n'est
pas exclu de pouvoir créer des problèmes
plus graves mais les recrues devant la
recrue de son de vaccins enfin l'ia et
mécanique
l'iaa est là l'acte d'être intelligent
na na na rien qui puisse demander de
nouvelles lois de la physique
on n'a pas besoin d'un break tout on n'a
pas besoin d'une révolution certains
laissant entendre qu'il faut une
révolution physique en fait par exemple
il n'y a rien dans les lois actuelles de
la physique
exclu le fait d'automatiser tous les
actes qu'on juge être intelligent et et
quand bien même on n'a pas encore tout
automatiser ce qui a déjà été
automatisées pour le dessin problème et
il faut le faire de manière contrôlée
superbe
bon je pense qu'on va finir sur sa donc
j'ai pas mal de recommandations sur
d'autres trucs 2010 précitée un livre
que tu reconnais comme ça ou de livre
que tu recommandé par une telle marque
peut-être non je pense que oui ça dépend
de l'audience pour ceux qui sont un peu
dans des cursus de maths etc
il ya un bouquin qui est pas mal sur la
complexité
elle était c'était en fait c'était un
bouquin de célébration de la vie de
gérard valin kiss donc je te donne rien
en fait c'est un bouquin qui était
dirigée par les embouts tous qui aborde
plusieurs aspects la complexité
algorithmique etc c'est un peu technique
et il est laissé aux ouailles
philosophers sous lequel a pas de
compétition la complexité ses parents
son excellent jeu au candidat c'est
vraiment en fait
un essai qui est très accessible et qui
sensibilise une audience non
informatiques a pour pourquoi en fait
les éléments conceptuels de la
complexité sont très utiles dans fait
des philosophes il ya un an dans une
dans une direction un peu similaire en
fait ce que ça va bientôt paraître ce
que j'écris avec dominique boullier fait
des éléments conceptuels de la
complexité liora pas de lien mais je
donnerai un pic à la sociologie ou en
fait pourquoi elle est pourquoi dans les
sciences sociales en fait il faut
conceptualiser les complexités les
différentes manières de dévaluer les
complicités dont échantillonnage temps
de calcul mémoire et c'est pourquoi
c'est un outil épistémologique qui n'est
pas si qui voit la clinique n'est pas de
trop pour il sa place qu'il mérite sa
place dans les sciences sociales
j'espère qu'on va mettre ça sur arxiv
marché ouverte entrée comme ça et puis
après je viens et mes angoisses je pense
que les cdc darroussin nous fait déjà la
sphère huawai philosophe tout cas comme
les chèques city c'est je pense la seule
recommandation que j'ai laissé ok mais
faut c'est un truc à lyon je crois aussi
très vivement ce truc de ce super papier
de squatteurs en turquie aussi au regard
des mecs rentrée très cool enfin qui
promet beaucoup et la complexité merci
beaucoup
mehdi et aux autres je vous dis à
bientôt probablement